si vous êtes déjà je passais déjà mais
il ya un truc très marrant je peux vous
dire un truc très drôle c'est que en
organique en organique de chats
organique on est plus avec ce raid que
que pendant tout le speech chasse
habituel quoi on n'a jamais eu un raid
même avec les premières pages avec 299
personnes
c'est exceptionnel surtout que ça a fini
à une heure où il ya beaucoup plus de où
il ya beaucoup plus de monde
enfin c'est marrant c'est marrant vite
fait 1
ça m'amuse pas du tout ça ne m'amuse pas
du tout bon je dois remettre les bons
noms ça j'ai pas ça c'est le truc que je
n'ai pas pu faire alors par contre j'ai
pas dans quel sens ils vont jouer donc
je vais mettre ça comme ça mais ça
devrait être un massacre en faveur de
giang pour moi je suis pas trop mal
quand même
j'ai pas trop mal géré le truc j'ai pas
trop mal géré le truc
de france 3
alors bonjour vers l'islande eyes team
sahara n'a ici moi team duction gains je
dis tout de suite
moi j'espère un massacre du coup les
matchs de fil rouge à terme et barry les
devants il est il est à l'écran un c'est
qui ce sahara n'a très très fort fait
très attention
grand favori du speech s adultes
d'ailleurs ça très dangereux je suis de
faire mes trucs techniques
j'en ai encore à faire
j'en ai encore à faire et après on est
bon
prenez bon pendant des heures c'est
terrible c'est terrible pakistan
indépendant wes arana je pense qu'il est
dans une maison de campagne
je pense qu'il est dans une maison de
campagne sarama en russie les gens ont
souvent une maison de campagne
mais là en plus avec le corona et tous
je vous construction je participe à lens
et lyon qui a réfléchi je me fais des
petites têtes bizarre une date charest
exactement sur la mer noire
pas forcément j'ai donc envoyé au fond
du bac qui se tendaient d'après là un
bon internet prélat pu la faire relier
j'en sais rien après peut-être que chez
lui il a il a une pièce comme ça c'est
les rues son design des fois spéciale 1
c'est pas le design baggies tanné qu'on
retrouve avec piscine terrasse et où un
lacet ça peut être spécial et bonsoir
attar zolder je vous préviens on se
regarde tranquille le match mais alors
vraiment tranquille tiens c'est parti
j'ai envie de vous dire sans forcer je
vous cache pas que je suis assez heureux
qu'on sur demi finale là on touche on
touche le bout mais je suis pas au bout
de mes peines parce qu'il ya le speech
as adultes qui va démarrer avec
exactement le même format cependant ce
pitch est adulte tu seras plus marrant
parce que son aura des belles affiches
direction une drague au sinn
ça a l'air de connaître un cerf de jouer
des grandes variantes là mais bon
jefferies qui doit être effrayé un par
sarah n'a fait pelops mais tu joues
odeurs maxime toi le speech à ce que tu
es ma du coup ils sont sympa à suivre
évidemment mais mais mais tata des dates
tu sais quelque chose puisque en fait
moi je sais vraiment rien je sais que ça
va avoir lieu
t'imagines mais tata une date à quelque
chose
c'est une info a lâché novembre ou
décembre est ok donc après les candidats
et/ou et le championnat du monde de
bulles est tu as des infos ou pas du
tout ou pas d'un faux nom donc c'est à
dire ça peut être bientôt je sais pas ce
qu'ils vont nous pondre
mais je m'attends au pire mais je
m'attends au pire
donc cette position est en train de tout
chèque pour voir si tout est bien partie
plaignante de bull est un [ __ ] c'est
le fait que s'arrêtant impuissants ou tu
trolles comment ce temps un + 0 premier
à 18,3 à rien trois sets gagnants et tu
trolles mais c'est possible en plus une
heure de pause entre les sept
aïe aïe aïe et le pire c'est qu'ils sont
capables de le faire
bon ça envoie du coup comme france hier
j'ai eu un problème non soit si ça
marche
cette fois ci ça fonctionne non le
marathon je le proposais mais faut que
faut que j'écrive bien faut que je fasse
une belle proposition
sa mission ne comptera que tu regardes
ce ton anaser pas leurs richesses ouais
exactement arthur turin je demanderai
d'un petit peu resté respecter le
tournoi quand même il ya quand même des
affiches de grande qualité arthur tueur
c'est quand même pas quand même ça rana
construction de la tension arthur tueur
petit peu faut faire un peu attention
vous respecter le contrat qualitatif
aussi oui non là en fait tu as été par
choix personnel ce serait terrible ce
serait terrible
ce serait terrible enlacés déjà
habituellement c'est dur à assumer la
côte à côte et à karlsson marché en
partie réelle et cta ça en même temps
bref c'est ça les affiches en soit en
vrai si le match durait une heure une
heure et demie seraient une affiche
sympa mène deux heures à la rigueur ça
dure entre 1h20 et une et deux heures
ce serait sympa mais mais oui clairement
le truc qui dure quatre heures et la fin
c'est ça qui casse tout en fait c'est
parce que tout le monde pense comme ça
en fait vraiment pas où on en parle à
chaque fois mais ça fait tellement
l'unanimité et ça fait tellement des
années que ça fait l'unanimité la 1h30
c'est le plat chaud fouet
c'est marrant la programmation aussi
étonnante mais plus on recule chaise
comme us ça c'est terrible
c'est terrible jusqu'à us en sueur
normand plus c'est vrai dans la
programmation est terrible en vraiment
par les espagnols qui ont une première
page leur côté qu'ils ont un peu de
monde mais oui y'a personne nulle part
on s'en fout ça extraordinaire hier ça
me faisait de la peine d'ailleurs quand
je regardais a et b 5 c'est bien jouer
et d'apprendre et 5 et 6 324 ans de
vente chaise comme b ap wave terrible
hausse est taillé pour czech comme ça
fait très très mal
ils ont mis six ans chez ce cas ils sont
montés
ah c'était ça a été terrible pour eux ça
aurait été terrible
ça a été un coup très dur
super match en perspective c'est génial
mais je vous ai déjà raconté en fait
qu'à la fin de la saison dernière des
speechs s rien on n'est pas sain car oui
mais parce qu'il y avait la première
page twitter en vrai on était tout le
temps entre 250 et 500 wen en fait le
truc marrant c'est que l'année dernière
l'année dernière il était en mode ouais
les compétitions les fera plus court
soit le pitch est féminin rouge fitch
est junior c'était trop long et tout
résultat c'est encore plus long que
l'année dernière ouais c'est
extraordinaire mais bon ça c'était
l'effet confinement qui revient on
regarde un peu les diables aussi d'une
héroïne chasse ça je peux le faire si
ruud je pense est un bug sur l'échiquier
non
j'ai l'impression le caruana tahri tard
y perdra jamais ça ça à faire nul au
mieux pour caruana et les vont aller bon
il va choisir entre le pion pendant ou
le pion isoler et ce qui fait les pions
pendant et ce qui est fait et pion isolé
un choix terrible pour ba qui ça et ce
qu'ils désavouent complètement magnus
les pions pendant il fait cavaler prend
ou fou prend vont plutôt qu'avec les
prouesses qui fait pions prend et baky s
c'est magnus qui va choisir way up aquis
dans le chat la faune
s'il fait pas les pions pendant ces ça
fait très très mal il a beaucoup plus
que 2006 50 je ne peux pas me permettre
va qui fait dépenser détrompe toi
face à un tel il fait aussi cavalier
pensée cinq ans au bac s
bakiyev à fond dans le chatt assez
terrible
oh c'est terrible vous avez vu ça en
direct les amis magnus carlsen refuse de
jouer les pions pour nous face à un
adversaire beaucoup trop fort pour qu'il
puisse le faire
ministre également sur des avoués en
direct rien n'est pas triomphant dans
ces durs assez durs pour le pakistan qui
prend un grand coup de bambou derrière
la tête
il va
déjà trop championnat team aaa baky qui
va se venger
alors il se passe quoi là entre nos deux
génies emile à 60 points elo de plus
sarah nasa rigole pas un ballet tour d
un an peut-être un petit tour d un
naturel et dame b 8
mais sarah nairo fait comme la daf en
fait ils jouent tous tempo il fait de la
merde temporada dit l'ordi d'un met fin
à ouidah dame afin d'affiner la partie
oui effectivement
effectivement un cavalier e 5 3 5 ya
plus d'échecs et damache un math
bah oui place a fait mal à cava lieu un
bien joué j'avais pas vu bon il faut
prendre c'est un epr enlève de ou
prendre f2 direct oui
mais sarah m'a vraiment un style bizarre
j'ai l'impression que c'est un genre de
maxime faible alors la lorgnette en
marlou il propose d'amener six échecs on
extraordinaire et d'un même si c'est
cheikh adam f 6 échecs c'est beau damas
fils échec c'était vraiment beau ceku
d'ordi mais c'est vraiment joli ça
honnêtement je sais pas si max aurait
trouvé ça mais c'est vraiment beau roy
prend 1,6 pour prendre sur échec
trouvable trouvable mais très dur trouva
mais très durs d'un même si ces chèques
attendez il a raté un truc il a raté
quoi ça s'est vu à la cam il a raté dame
eu un rush de et g41 et matt imparable
et dans son ordre de coups et g3
imparable et dans son ordre de coûts g4
agf gdam f1 ouais c'est terrible il a il
a laissé d'un méfait en fait ouais c'est
bête
c'est un gros raté de la part de de jong
bon il reste au mieux quand même il est
un pion de plus et le roi blanc et un
peu réseauter mais le problème c'est que
ces options il est fort là peut-être c4
est aidé à me prends à sète au joli au
joli le pat haut salat je l'avais pas à
très mignon le path
ah oui ça c'était beau ça pour la peine
on rigole on rigole mais c'était
vraiment beau le dame prend 1,7 et
d'am-dam échec avec le pad c'est très
élégant la part de savannah saada qui se
présente way et qui joue une âge d'orb
derrière ça c'était c'était vraiment
sympathique
non il n'est pas allé prendre la qualité
je n'étais pas bon ah non ça c'était
vraiment joli pour la peine on rigole on
rigole mais donc fausse être pas
possible on y apprend que cette dame
prend 1,8 ya toujours cavalier système
prend à 8 sous le coude
ce que les joueurs voient les calmes de
la gamme leurs adversaires ou ici
veulent mais je pense pas qu'ils
regardent honnêtement épique zhiyong on
voit pas trop hein j'ai regardé un peu
vers le bas nanjing
non tu en vois pas trop sa bouche ou
quoi tu sais pas voilà on voit même plus
ses yeux c'est même plus où il regarde
elle a pas centré sa tête ouais mais bon
du coup on ne voit pas un sais pas où
ils regardent il fait ses 4 j'ai une
bonne une bonne sensation pour les
blancs le développement des noirs parés
paraît compliqué
ça paraît compliqué pour les noms après
c'est concret mais donc on verra puis on
prend vous prends moi y'a pas les micros
cette affaire les micros sont coupées
bon ok c'est quoi la ligne ses pions
prend fou prend admettons tour à cette
drogue flo7 genre un truc comme ça mais
bon ça pas une bonne tête là juste pour
dire ouais alors dit d'un loyer ainsi à
ça en fait genre ça pions prend fou
prend à 7 puis on prend ça me prendrait
5 on réattaque ici tours est fluide ça
sent que ça va pas le roi noir est trop
centrale annonce et je sais pas si pour
vous ça paraît visuel aussi mais moi il
peut déjà faire casser cette tout
prendre allait prendre à sa 8è à 5
ça suffit déjà donné l' avantage
fo qui mettre les poings actions qu'il a
déjà raté la première il faut mettre le
point ici côté côté jefferies c'est très
important
c'est très important de de commencer à
construire le score par exemple qu'à mon
avis gros favoris rien justement il fait
les cas et c'est cette dame à 8
alors il n'a pas d'âme prend à 5 tout de
suite parce qu'il ya ce à attaquer mais
tour c'est en plus sa menace une
découverte ce que la tour est protégée
il ya quoi moi y'a un pion pour la
qualité mais c'est les blancs qui ont
toute l'activité leroy hausse est en
plus il est super mal parce qu'il
obstrue le fouet il obstrue la tour
annoncé catastrophique pour à la foux
prend 1,6 c'est catastrophique pourra
pour sarah n'a ici c'est juste la
qualité de plus et les compensations
alors ils empêchent quand même rock
parce qu'il aura qu'un lieu de deux
mais bon il prend prend avait peut-être
quand même rock carré lieu de roy bush
qui est français un tour prend ses seins
et attaquer le roi a laissé une vraie
option ça en vrai ouais t'es une rupture
ça se voit tout de suite le roi est trop
mal on n'aura qu'un pion de moins pour
ce truc là d'ailleurs il prend même pas
il prend même pas le matériel il fait il
fait des 5
aya pas fou des quatre pour le moment à
cause de camaïeu de donc ça c'est pas
idiot appris à peut-être tout reprend
ses trois aidé à me prends des cinq qui
se regardent et iard ouachin qui se
regardent complètement aussi bien sûr
pour éviter tous les problèmes tour ces
deux rôles alors dit donne un coup de
marloux damage de roi proche d'eux et
fois et food et 6 quel marlou ce sahara
n'a donc tour à elle d un c'était le
même problème max qu'elle marlou ces
jolies d'un match de sart est moins bien
pour les noirs oui bien sûr mais tu vas
gagner à 2 ici et tu peux peut-être la
tenir et tu peux peut-être la tenir tout
à l'heure en fait tu risques et juste de
te faire mater rapidement sur au centre
de l'échiquier est ici tu as une finale
inférieur mais elle et nabeul isidro je
suis pas sûr max un prêt l'ordi est
d'accord avec toi tu donnes +0 30
j'aurais quand même pris g7 avec les
blancs mais tu dois avoir raison si toi
tu dis ça avec l'ordi donne la même et
valhalla l'ordi donne quasiment gagnante
pour les noirs après fou ses 5,3 g de d4
ah oui mais c'est hyper dangereux
ah oui mais c'est hyper dangereux parce
que y'a b3 à b2 à b1 qui arrive ah oui
mais tu as raison
là c'est carrément gagnant pour les
noirs bon bah j'avais comme une vision
que j'avais pas vu un désolé les gars je
n'étais pas au niveau
je n'étais pas au niveau je pensais faut
prendre g7 et les blancs presse je
comprenais pas pourquoi ça devait être
nulle c'est pour ça que j'ai les blancs
sont mieux mais maxime et l'ordi avez vu
ce truc là bas mais ils sont trop forts
maxime et l'ordi assez bien joué ça un
des quatre qui va bloquer la diagonale
du fou et b3 à b2 b1 qui va être
imparable
mais après il fallait faire le tour
prend ces trois dames prend des cinq par
contre ça j'avais bien senti j'avais pas
compris pourquoi mais j'avais bien
senties saf dans mon style
caractéristique pour continuer à
l'attaqué pas m'embêter fou des six
dames point f7 après j'en rate parfois
des partis en faisant ça mais ça c'est
dans mon style typique
3 ces 8es bon allez peut-être prêt doit
être gagnante avait peut-être pas si
simple encore à faire mais sûr que c'est
mieux que ce qu'il a fait parce que là
on en est où maintenant prêt donc il a
pris ces trois et là le truc c'est que
le roi va monter va aider les pions mais
amel damaggio était vraiment bien vu un
beau match de foot et si c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment bien joué
alors c'est pas encore fait il ya qu un
coût qui gagne après ces 3 6 6 3 b53 c4
qui est le plus logique quand même de
ramener le roi ici est de pousser le
problème c'est que sur des cas qui
aimerait croire qu'à 3 des trois mais
qui se voit quand même encore que ces
deux rois eu deux fois trois rois des
deux ça peut être tentant mais ça ça
défend qu'il faut calculer cette
variante là en fait parce que c'est vrai
que sinon des quatre équidés ces deux
fois 3 sat enfin quand même donc voici 3
b st croix c4 ce que j'aurais joué en
zite avec l'impression que je vais
pousser tout seul
alors à temps et ce qui peut faire tour
des huit tours ces huit des trois rois
des ens et de roi des deux ils te
demandent comment tu avances donc là
faut peut-être qu'on tournait avec trois
des quatre comme ça sur tour des huit
chefs et rois de quatre tours c8 ces
deux à ce moment là pour wade 5 c'est la
même idée salue avec give you to coast
fort nuke
j'adore ton interview que le précepteur
set up merci c'était un moment très
sympa ouais c'est bien j'ai en fait ce
qu'il veut c'est ces deux rois d2 et
surtout b4y l'horaire on apprend des 3%
qui fait tomber quatre maintenant avec
idc de roi c'est un fou à 3 et dames
elle n'est pas si simple encore
peut-être mais c'est bien le roi des
quatre ils rentrent pas dans la finale
c'est pour ça qu'ils abandonnent il
préparer ces deux fois trois échanges et
roi de 3 ha et ça en a qui fait mal en
début de match là donc ça fait un an et
demi 1/2 on va jeter un oeil aux autres
partis magnus carlsen yuko avec son pur
isolés contre les vols
il semble avoir assez d'activité caruana
il a toujours cette petite finale
ce que je trouve légèrement désagréable
et duda et 12 il ya un bug alors ils ont
mis le score dans l'autre sens ailleurs
qu'il faut changer les têtes tu peux
jamais savoir dans quel sens ils vont le
mettre en fait
mais le problème est réglé
mal on retourne là dessus à se repasser
l'ouverture là c'est un bon guide à
m'accepter au final enfin selon sapa
l'une viennoise ce truc là les refusant
dans un premier temps ils acceptent dans
un deuxième
damned
trois cas ça ne joue pas pourquoi cassin
joue c'est pas ce pitch junior à mme
carlsson il joue le norway chess du coup
qu'on peut pas sûr parce qu'on doit
suivre ça
mais mon âme ces deux
mais bon normalement il reste plus de
deux matchs de ce pitch est celui-là et
la finale je prends pas qu'il y ait de
match pour la troisième place
belkacem faire le purise l'option
pendant sarah nahla qui a bien joué les
prêts en fait il était malin dans les
deux premières il les a retourné
finalement il aurait pu être mené 2 0 et
ils mènent d'un point et du coup c'est
vrai que s'ils commencent à construire
le score ça peut faire mal
après les matchs sont loin c'est à dire
quatre heures moment sera bien sûr
d'avoir le meilleur qui gagne c'est
quand même l'avantagé d'être bien sûr
quand il fait h4 ça ils aiment bien
maintenant faire ch 4 avec les idées de
faire des karellis g5 et d'attaquer le
roi c'est quelque chose qu'ils aiment
beaucoup faire
encore une heure de cinq plus un vrai
bas qui a baissé
quand je lis que c'est terrible c'est
terrible hein quand tu appelles et que
je te dis que je suis un peu chez un peu
fatigué tout c'est pas pour rien un cfc
dur
alors
et bonjour mathieu sm je suis pas bien
pour toi
non mais là ça reste deux matches je
fais quatre ans de screamo moi j'espère
j'espère bien oui j'espère bien max
sinon on est malin il fait à six
ce qui va faire cavaler ces trois
policiers affaire qui avait jugé cinq en
premier ça la question que je me pose
en vrai well as la cadence bull est un
peu et un peu dommage à la fin
finalement je trouve donc ça dure
tellement longtemps que c'est relou qui
s'ajuste sur des bulles est quand ça
joue sur des bullet et quand les matchs
se sont décidés avant les bullet sont
superflus et servent à rien du coup il
ya quelque chose qui va pas qu'est ce 3
et puis on des quatre ans prises ouais
mais après il ya tellement d' attaque
parce que là aussi dès que tu bouges à
des quatre ans prises mais mais il ya de
la taxe sur le roi mais ça doit être la
variante principal inquiets 6 3 qui
prend des quatre peut-être dame 4g pas
qu'elle prend aux deux dames h4 qui
juste comme ça extrêmement compliqué
peut-être bien pour les noirs au final
pour elle commence pas par les bulles
est ce serait pas idiot à w en réalité
donc assise jouer
qui est aussi dames 4 comme coup avec
idées sur fion prendre prendre ces 6
c'est peut-être plus malins d'ailleurs
de commencer par dame e 4 vous proposez
pas de coût aussi dans le chatt 1 mais
commencer par d'avocate et peut-être
malin
ça peut être même très malin
ce qui fait d'ailleurs c'est logique on
a mis pas mal de temps à arriver à cette
conclusion nous aussi et je suis en
train de dire sur pions prend dame prend
d'amd 5 pour essayer d'échanger dame
prend 6,7 et penny puisque ça attaque là
et aussi ici
ouais non c'est vrai je recule patron
que c'est bizarre d'allonger les caves
ans après le truc
le truc en fait c'est qu'on est on
essaie de réparer un truc qui marche pas
donc ses maîtres de la rustine sur un
pneu crevé en fait c'est à ton plus qui
est attendu d'eux qui est défoncée tu
mets un peu de réussite pour réparer en
vrai y'a rien qui va faut tout revoir de
zéro c'est tout ça va il défend pas mal
la dame courage cette latour couvre 6
les pions retrouver du liant en soi
c'est plutôt bien ce qui fait pour
défendre giang
coûteux regroupe 122 rue sinon ça c'est
ce qu'ils font pour le moment et chaque
année à québec a très bien joué
il joue sur le clouage et il veut
rebondir vers détroit ou verser 2 il a
fait un excellent enchaînements de coups
là jean guy meyer seignal sarine qui a
battu avec haïkus mais vous avez dit que
ça se prononcer
pénible ça il va être obligé de la carte
mais il doit peut-être faire petit rock
comme 10 fr mais si tu fais petit rock
tu perds la pression sur la colonne h
c'est dommage mais peut-être que tu dois
le faire hein voilà un exemple qui a
bien joué thaler il se faire arnaquer à
la fin on va voir si ça continue un peu
dans ce dans ce registre il m'a l'air
d'être plus fort après c'est vrai qu'il
est plus fort en longue mais à mesa rana
a l'air d'être très affûté
fou qui revient au carat on sent que les
pièces noires sont bien placés là il est
mieux autant il peut alors décider de
fouet 5 pour échanger les fous et ils
lui donnent des quatre pour replacer
l'oeuf ou sur la diagonale mais le truc
c'est que le car il y tient la case 2,5
donc ça sera dur de se mettre en
batterie fouet dame voyez je suis
d'accord avec toi tu joues le vrai c'est
abusé le nombre de bullet qui avait par
rapport aux autres cadence j'ai trouvé
ça aussi un petit peu étrange parce
qu'ils avaient plus de bulles est que de
trois plus un et 2 5 + 1 ça paraissait
vraiment disproportionnée après ça
avantage est grandement n'a qu'a donc
c'était peut-être aussi un des objectifs
inavoués
mais en soit c'était pas ça paraissait
pas naturel en fait on n'a pas
l'habitude que les que les cadences les
plus courtes sur les plus importantes
wen a qu'à gagner en finale dans un
match serré contre fedoseyev qui a fait
son match
non mais là le truc ce qu'avec les noirs
il a un qui ont de plus et commence à
avoir de l'activité
donc ya pas de raison qu'ils soient
moins bien
par contre dans le petit jeu tactique
qui se fait souvent prendre par sarah là
il a réussi à installer son four enfin
réussir à progresser il ya quand même
des fous de couleur opposait le fou
détroit est bien placé mais un peu
décoratifs
alors il va y avoir un changement à f3
peut-on que l'expression pipeline your
pampers et l'emportent peu importe
ah oui il ya toujours cette matin par
able assez terrible peu importe c'est
terrible il se refait il se faire
arnaquer désolé j'ai pas suivi je
pensais que la finale allait être
tranquille est longue mais il a raté que
le fou ces trois contrôles et f6 exemple
qui se refaire un hacker à l'effort 1
sarah naïl arnaque bien troisième partie
où ils se retrouvent mal et troisième
fois qu ils arnaquent je pense que deux
invasions que serait le score minimum
logique et finalement il ya deux ans et
demi un demi en faveur du joueur russe
vision qui se fait vraiment trop
arnaquer vos cils sarah naret est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'il a un style de
maxime en beaucoup moins fort
est ce qu'on peut se permettre
mais du coup je donne pas cher de la
peau de giang au final
maintenant on regarde moi ces belles
nage dans fouet c'est vraiment maxime
ont beaucoup moins fort quoi c'est
marrant et il est bon en longues maxime
sahara n'a ou pas un maxi moins fort ça
reste fort vite fait un passé moins fort
que maxime quoi ils jouent comme maxime
et ont pu nul
il ne sera jamais au dessus de 2007 je
crois qu'on peut en être sûr
mais il menacera jamais d'être dans les
meilleurs du monde dans max enfin il est
quand même moins moins virulent que toi
ça alors de kobe de 15 quoi il fait pas
peur à grand monde
moi je demanderais sarradin pourquoi tu
vois
non mais elle était belle cette
punchline de vlad pourquoi tu joues quoi
pourquoi tu joues ça fait combien de
temps que tu n'as pas gagné un tournoi
c'est génial trois ans
non plus je pense que vlad tap a gagné 1
grande chaise tout bourrin biche kenzy
les candidats ou un truc comme ça ça ne
compte pas en plus un bon là il va
vouloir jouer à le pion des six
bhatti qui veut le cap d'agde online
c'est terrible ça c'est quand des
arbakis truc là
je veux dire est ce qu'on peut et c'est
un truc genre cavalli ou trois accusés
de faire car eev 5 et sur pions prend
torje 3 mais le problème c'est qu'il
pourra reprendre du fou c'était une idée
de marloux c'est fin octobre mais ça va
pas de prendre trop de temps par rapport
à la prépa des candidats
tant le train c'est pas mal aussi
moi j'aime bien cette tour ici un pape
la fin et maxime est sain par compris b4
je pense qu'il veut avait quatre à cinq
et karel et b6
voir qui avait six cavaliers ou guillon
qui se lève c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible
dans ces quatre tours des quatre temps
c'est quoi l'idée b3 admettons tour des
quatre étapes et larbi temps mais
complètement en pignon pampers à détroit
j'ai pas trop compris deux tours des 4
as well as bien vu il a envie de pisser
pourquoi ils finissent pas entre les
parties la cuisse bien vu
marie fait faire pipi dans ces pans père
ça c'est arrivé là ce qu'il a fait et
xing
non mais bon t'as pas droite a pas le
droit pink panthers
et puis pas et puis basta vous pensez
vraiment qu'ils allaient faire pipi
cette terrible aller faire pipi comme ça
en plein milieu de partie
il a fait p3 et l'autre a pas fait
tourner quatre pas donc il a fait pour
faire à b5 ouais ce que j'ai pensé dans
un deuxième temps la jambe au prochain
speech à ses obligations genre de
prévoir leur stock de pompaire serait je
pense pour le speech assurant que tu
trolles la cam que tu étais pampers quoi
que tu montes des pampers à la caméra
c'est exceptionnel je vais acheter un
paquet de pampers tiens je pense que je
vais acheter un sachet de pompaire ce
que je montrerai à la cam de temps en
temps il doit vouloir mettre le cavalier
ans et 7 pour couper la connexion des
tours et attaqué des six pompes r c'est
exceptionnel donc fait d'un f3 femme et
ses beaux dans des pampers avec soi
kwapis pignan pompaire se dégage mais
quelle est cette tête il veut pas perdre
le pion à b3 par contre on peut se poser
les roland garros où il va zy une façon
on va pas revoir les matchs en redif un
djoko qualifie alors contre 4 à 9 plutôt
rajaona of je vois russe d'origine
arménienne
ouais c'était sûr
ce 4 6 4 6 3 way il va peut-être
retrouver d'ailleurs qui a réuni au
bugue bousseta dans un match à venir et
à mon avis il va pas être facile à
prendre car règne au buste à
cai qui en b 5
attention feu follet altmayer vrai nom
bien sûr
donc je vais regarder l'histoire du
tennis tient pas manquer pendant qu'ils
réfléchissent à ça mais whip my hair
bien sûr très dangereux montferrand qui
s'est fait breaké mais c'est que le
début et karen o bus arrêt dangereux
altmeyer bon allez il va prendre en d6
là il est vraiment gagnant f5 c'était
bizarre et xoom qui pour le moment
domine toutes les parties on est tout à
fait d'accord on est tous d'accord avec
ça lille domine
il domine toutes les games et ce qui
peut être rassurant pour lui un sac il
faut qu'il se raccroche ses qui domine
vraiment
pourquoi pas flattant à seulement voilà
il le fait 1 mais avait aussi présents
des 6 1 qui est intéressant bref tout
qui tombe un côté à côté sarah n'a mais
plus que 20 secondes
donc ça peut être dangereux il prend
prend prend et qui revient en bessin qui
va prendre dès 6 ans rebond ce qui
rebondit sur la tour il va prendre des
six il va menacer f5 et si le pion point
il reprend du cavaly l'envoi la tour en
ouais c'est vrai que jong il finit il
gagne une partie finalement après être
parti de la caméra pendant une pendant
30 secondes
j'aimerais dire trop des pampers 1 prend
des pampers
qu'en pensent les eagles je pensais
qu'ils feraient dames c'est cet échec
ici mais bon peut-être qu'ils voulaient
la terre est attirée dans un traquenard
à et c'est bien joué ça y touche le fou
il aura cavale et à vii qui apprend aux
cinq peut-être sans compter les tours 17
cavaliers
cet échec est il pas bien la sarre ana
il est pas bien
j'adore faire bouger cette il va
échanger et peut-être faire dame ses
huit dames ces quatre dames f7
maintenant et ça gagne
allez ça fait à ça fait 2 1 me revient
un peu ging
c'est vraiment le score cadeau un pur
pour sarah n'a qui semble beaucoup moins
fort que son adversaire
sarah naess way
alexei nom le dit qu'il fait liocha en
russe et pas alex théret tête ou cinq
noms qui va arriver
weedon dessins que c'est bien ils
attaquent la tour au passage cavalière
trois dames prend d un essai un peu
mieux pour les noirs pardon meilleure
structure de pions et les blancs peuvent
plus rockets aliocha c'est un prénom
aliocha liocha liocha non-lieu ou chassé
alex est du coup en cours il ya aliona
qui a un prénom et du coup le diminutif
7 aliocha ouais mais c'est un diminutif
aussi liocha c'est comme ça j'ai pour
alexander est du coup alexei celio
champs et à lyon à cette allure charest
ça c'est clairement mieux pour les noirs
après c'est pas forcément gagnant mais
il ya un pion faible ans et 3,07 à le
chat ça alexei dans les frères karamazov
rim est du coup en fait c'est le même
prénom près de manda aliéna pour le
diminutif alexandre sacha je sais pas
pourquoi
rezki férois e7 b6 b si c'est pas mal ça
solidifier ça libère le cavalier de la
tâche défensive et tout miser sur ce
pion genre v6 3,7 hors ces huit
cavaliers à 4 ou cavalier e 4 pour
attaquer le pion c3
on va voir comment comment ils
continuent ces pays si swatch passe me
paraissait logique si tu commencé comme
ça mais je sens un coin bien joué
non mais c'est vous tous les gens qui
pensent qu'ils pensaient se terre dans
le chat que faire un
que faire des vidéos sur l'histoire des
échecs c'était simple losrque c'est un
sujet ultra complexes peut-être même
plus complexe que le jeu en lui même
la question c'est que s'ils semblent
pour moi je pense qu'il ya pas assez de
matériel pour la gagne et ça là je pense
c'est juste nul ça mais bon
je vois pas comment tu la presse on va
faire un petit tour sur les autres
échiquiers sur les échiquiers du nord
which s on à karlsson qui s'activent
il a bien raison parce qu'avec un pur
avec isolé il faut jouer actifs
ariane tahri qui a son pion de plus mais
à voir la kawasaki aura assez de jeux
qui arriveront c4 et duda c'est la
partie qui a buggé mais qui a des bogeys
il a bien fait trois quatre dames 4 ça
ça peut être un peu dans le dur
ce qui va se prendre un fou un f6 qui va
défendre le roi est attaqué en b2g une
expo sur les échecs c'est pas sa
renommée l'histoire les échecs c'est un
sujet tellement vaste et complexe
c'est hyper complexe faire des vidéos
dessus c'est hyper compliqué
hypercomplexes ça va pour les blancs il
ya juste injuste pions faible
ouais tolstoï guerre et paix c'est bien
c'est vraiment pas mal
ça c'est nul
nefa 5 à 1 tour b 5 peut-être maintenant
pour échanger sur tours c4 tombé 4 ça
c'est bien nul les gars ça je peux vous
le dire c'est bien nul
il reste encore une grosse demi-heure de
5 + 1 après on aura notre petite pause
petite pause qui fait plein
ces quatre tours b 4 et tour des cinq
majeur avec tour des quatre traits
pleutre pourrait changer mais ton dessin
que c'est pas bête
c'est pas c'est pas assez pour gagner
ces derniers proposent ni jefferies avec
les noirs c'est plutôt lui qui pressent
saana devra accepter
là
baki cissé marcher dessus dans le chat
il la joue je sais pas trop il joue ça
j'ai pas à quel moment c'est les blancs
qui sont mis à presser en fait
je trouve coincé les blancs qui doivent
presser ça va juste faire tour 17
aïe le tour des cinq mêmes ça ce sera
nul
même tour des 5 comprend des 5 sera
nullement quand bien même tu réussis à
faire ça tu vas pas plus loin ce que tu
peux faire c'est un truc comme ça
là et on prend des cinq ceni le
directeur
dans les blancs qui peuvent jamais faire
un plan comme ça s'arrête quand le roi
arrivant à j-6 il va y avoir b5 et à un
vrai même quand ils arrivent en h5
si je peux faire j'ai g4 comprend prise
b5 ça ça ok il est encore dans le car et
tu peux aller jusqu'en g4 mais pas plus
loin dès que tu vends h5 tu te prends le
pion de l'autre côté ayem mb 5 ab à 5
ans maxime exacte et b6
ouais tu vas pas pouvoir passer de même
pas faire j'ai quatre et la b5
mais ça c'est d'être drôle
ouais ça va faire nul logique
on va retourner dans la nage dorff ça
repart pour la vente avec h3 ça se passe
pas mal pour guillon gains quand même
qui a réussi à resserrer les dents
j'arrive pour éviter de résoudre les
positions dit maxime qui va jouer un
grand roque là je pense jefferies
il va jouer gros je pense
et si prend b3 il pourra reprendre 2
c'est peut-être et maître laurent b 1
un peu comme dans la partie fischer
larsen prix du pion cm ans il prend du
pion à président français qui des rois
b1 est cachée droit c'est pas idiot ça
me semble être une possibilité mais
m'ont prise doit pourquoi pas aussi un
et demain il y aura le title tuesday
avec cette mazet
opposé à sanaa le mc de l'abbé ap on
pourra lui proposer du avec nous la
saison prochaine en pro chasse higuain
mais peut-être pas mauvais le bonhomme
ça pourrait peut-être un renfort en vrai
pourrait peut-être nous nous renforcer
qu'à leur nom dans cette manie qui sera
là il m'a écrit ce matin il m'a dit
qu'il avait fait un super stage avec
quelques membres de la baie ap il a eu
sept 7 membres de la bea paix avec lui
qui ont bien progressé pour les soldes
battle non car il est là il va il veut
se diriger vers la case des 5
juste pour dire leur dis propose de tout
prendre et si si si qui est pas facile à
voir pour complètement vis et avec la
qualité de deux mois et mon sens blitz
est quasiment impossible à jouer
alors le roi qui part en b1 progressé
pour le title on verra il va peut-être
prendre de la dame pour viser la case
âge si c'est un petit peu et viser aussi
de l'autre côté viser les cases noires
qui sont abandonnés par les noirs est la
tour d un dam des deux ça va tripler
ça a l'air d'être cool ça pour pour
notre ami jefferies selon l'abbé ap qui
veilleront à garder leurs droits dans le
carré des pions tête aux singes berly ce
que ben ali était au stage du coup j'ai
un doute là à et d'amd de ce dont je
vous parlais le triple h sur la colonne
des six mois qui payent le stage c'était
pas un tarif très très cher un café
mazella sabah pour pour ce stage là
c'était c'est est un stage avec remise
pour les abos abyss reader x quelques
d'ea mobile dream en fait donc au moins
c'est simple pas de bluff côté seb
il n'y a pas eu de bluff non moi comme
je disais j'essayerai de faire un gros
truc mais une fois que cowitz sera
terminé il n'y avait pas un mais une
invité mystère à ce stage vers toi honte
à vue en fin d'été stagiaires pour
mettre les échiquiers quoi alors
j'arrive à échanger
les halles faille chic y est mais celle
qui la veille avait une fille enfin sont
à mille et une invité mystère mais tu
vas nous dire qu'ils s'étaient eux on
sera demain en tout cas les gens qui ont
plus de voir ses les stagiaires qui ont
pu te rencontrer un max ou pas du coup
tu l'auras bien diderot ça va la chaîne
bitstream d'ailleurs ça c'est très
important
extrêmement important ça at-elle avant
leur arrivée les talus personnes pas
juste mis les échiquiers en fait donc tu
as
pas pu faire le boulot nakba qui invité
mystère au travers de longs maxima
exactement
barbarella revendre mazères terrible moi
je savais faire un truc mais oui quand
dams et 5 il n'y a pas un tourcoing fc
tours c'est cette max aya roi 8
qu'est ce que c'est bien vu am il est
fort maxime c'est terrible le petit roi
8 qui fait plaise
il a vu ou pas
il a vu et pas mal ce sahara na 3-6 tour
des cinq maria faire tour dames c'est
cette dame 3
reste quand même un pion plus sain pour
les blancs et j'imagine qu'il ya du g4
qui va partir sayah tête damas est ici à
mesdames à sept y aura tous réussissent
très bien totalement faire marcher un
damas sept tours f6 tour des six tours
prend tout reprend f7 mais bon je suis
sans ordi je vais mettre leur vie en
vérification à partir d'ici à mai adam
français 2 3 à 2 et ouais du coup c'est
les noirs qu'attaquant premier
complètement raté il a fait tour à sept
du gundam b5 dam des trois d'accord on
laisse pas rentrer ça c'est logique
et maintenant il ya tout reprend f7 et
dames 17
là ça passe ça sa clôture la game
annoncé deux pions de plus ea le roi
noir est ouvert
voilà c'est bon là
peut-être dante 8 non c'est trop
pleutres façon d'un bep 5 donnes ta dam
et 55 ans qui peut même pas d'âme des
huit pleutre et salaires efficace hein
damas 7 c'est bien joué
sur des cinq tours f7 f3 d'alger 1 à
l'accord il prend ici
rice et refaire arnaquer il ya tour f1
qui arrive
ah non il ya tour à sept tours à cette
frise à cet essai perpète
il sait d'eux nous fait nous de nouveau
faire arnaquer c'est terrible
non mais je peux pas te faire sans arrêt
arnaquer comme ça c'est terrible de se
faire arnaquer comme ça miss farhan haq
a toutes les gammes en fait
zhang c'est incroyable c'est vraiment
incroyable
ah ouais non mason
il se prend tous les pièges qui peuvent
exister au monde quoi c'est c'est du
génie c'est du génie tous les pièges qui
se prend c'est spectaculaire
c'est vraiment spectaculaire
ouais il n'a pas le bon mais méritée
ouais non c'est spectaculaire ficelé
j'ai vraiment tout prison
ils ont ils à tout est changé mon sahara
faire annuler un charme son qu'il est
tellement plus fort qui ont en fait mais
il se prend tous les pièges
voilà le dernier thé sévère qu'elle a
fait le tour premier set il avait tout
fait quoi comme quoi hein quand tu
comptes des mecs vraiment fort même un
joueur comme vision qui a du mal à finir
il est pas rêver non non je crois
vraiment que votre façon il a plus des
lots sarah main donc c'est que il ya
bien une raison parce qu'il est tout le
temps moins bien ou en tout cas il y a 6
il est parti si tu enlèves les arnaques
section qui devrait mener de deux ou
trois points et il est mené d'un point
donc c'est bien que que sarah night for
quelques parrains
ils trouvent des pièges il trouve les
pièges finale est un peu sans histoire
c'est symétrique au niveau des pions et
alcarez les contre le fou
mais c'est rien c'est un de pouvoir
faire un tour sur le norway chess alors
aronian karl scène égal pour le moment
sur ce pion isolé sajoo chance
réciproque
taris contre caruana ya toujours le pion
plus mais lecavalier en décidera vents
forts donc chaud et duda arrêt doute
attendait y en avait une deuxième salle
à faut la fermer et duda s dame assise
sur une idée de prise prises en ce sens
que c'est plutôt ouvert sur le roi de de
jean-christophe mais bon il un pion plus
avoir on retourne sur notre match
d'un tueur pas jouer j'ai 4 way i là il
est parti sur une autre direction
assez tendue importe jefferies quand
même mené d'un point alors qu'il a
toutes les occasions pour prendre le
score
ça ressemble quand même un match qui va
mal tourner taillefer 1 h 5 pour
complètement bloquée à la pousser où il
veut acheter ce g5 changé 4
un temps dans cette cadence 28 40 qui a
encore deux parties après celle là et
maxime au tournoi de ce week-end se fait
éliminer en huitième de finale par un
certain alexander j'ai bien connu dans
le milieu
richard s'est fait exploser près par
artemiev au tour d'après artemiev a été
très bon un thé juste un peu déçu pour
lui qu on a cas il a vraiment est
vraiment du mal à lutter contre la
fatigue il joue en pleine nuit c'était
complexe et feydeau cf qui allait en
finale s'est qualifiée pour le speech s
ortie est agacé savait pas vraiment il a
fait des grosses gaffes artemiev était
4h du mat chez lui 1 et n'a qu'à et
gagne en finale contre feydeau cf mais
fedoseyev qui se qualifie pour le speech
s et syna cas était de sa numéro iris de
le rejouer d'ailleurs au premier tour
ça reste complètement égal cette finale
pour le moment
voir comment ça continue cette partie
était déjà faire un fou ces six autour
s'est vite pour échanger encore plus je
vous ferai h pas que c'est pas la partie
la plus passionnante du match mais bon
il faut les jouer c'est parti et pas les
perdre
c'est pas les plus vils voir
virevoltante metz elle rapporte un point
comme les autres et on sent que jong est
extrêmement attentif aux coups de son
adversaire qui semble pouvoir l'arnaqué
assez facilement et salua gabilla dans
le chat si longue et là car c'est vrai
qu'on voit on voit pas on va pas
vraiment sa tête c'est bizarre qu'il est
par cadrée alors qu'une partie sur la
sicilienne y aura trois parties is moule
pour un carton on voit un chinois
d'ailleurs c'est chiant que ces mêmes
gens que je croise france même plus
chaud que je suis en bon c'est déjà ça
trop stream ce soir et ouais normalement
je sais pas femme qui a fait partie
pédagogique où je suis pas on verra mais
où il y aura un autre stream après sera
pas forcément des échecs ce que je
l'exprimé depuis 17h mais bon il y aura
six la fin de ces parties là s'il ya des
nuls et ya d armageddon du norway ya pas
mal de choses à venir mais bon on doit
on doit on doit finir ce match speech s
compétition une personne ne souhaite
voir mais qui se joue quand même il
prend il réfléchit beaucoup trop
longtemps ici à vie donc je pensais
qu'il voulait faire pousser si ce qu'ils
avaient prévu pouces et six tours à 5 et
quelque chose mairie va commencer à se
faire
il va commencer à se faire tournicoter
il commence à se faire fixer faut qu'ils
soient méfiants
ça peut devenir dangereux
allez voir cavaler f5 j'imagine
ouais c'est chose faite peut être chaud
pour pour les noirs lecavalier la tour
qui sont dangereux quand ils jouent
ensemble
ça peut être extrêmement dangereux
il va falloir être méfiant côté noir
[Musique]
reste fait peur pour guillon qu'après
c'est souvent du calcul précis mais tour
c300 et que ça peut sauver ouais ce qu'a
récupéré b3 et peut-être super pas la
pièce mais je sens que sarah may est
quand même bien plus fort un sort des 8
ouais c'est hyper dangereux mais ce qui
m'a sevran qui est des six quais des six
y aurait 3 e set
il fait x 4 alors pourquoi pas fou b5
pour menacer maths en un sas et
mystérieux pour moi foulée 5 paraissait
tellement logique puisque sa menace
autour des 3 matt x 4 semble juste être
une gaffe
ouais d'ailleurs il est dégoûté
il comprend que c'était faux v5 le coup
ce que tu en prends à droite on prend à
cet échec est hyper tout bref au x 4 c
je comprends elle voulait juste faire
tout reprend 1,3 mais il est fou b5
maintenant c'est incroyable d'avoir à
tfo et 5ème chicane d'énormes fautes
action que ce soir je sais pas si c'est
mauvaise forme ou quoi ou caisse
mais oui il est écoeuré c'est un impôt
tout quoi ce qu'il avait il a juste
perdu un tempo hyper important et on
voit qu'ils s'en veut et cavaliers des
six qui prend b5
c'est terminé gaffe monumentale 1 x 4 ou
v5 gaffe monumentale de xiong well as à
dubaï
il en fait vraiment trop et des gravats
il fait vraiment des gaffes des des très
grosses gaffes et ça c'est un vrai
problème
non il en fait il en fait trop de
grosses gaffes jefferies salah elle
était encore importante un mois il s'est
mis mal à prendre pour rien je suis
d'accord car au niger il gère mal ses
parties 1
il gère mal ses parties mais
mais du coup on voit pas comment il peut
faire tourner le match en fait parce que
ça ils auraient pu corriger la position
n'était pas très complexe il a il
n'avait pas une position hyper compliqué
à gérer de base c'est pas la position tu
réfléchis des plombes quoi ce que je
veux dire
il s'est hissé mis dans le caca tout
seul quoi bon après peut-être il va il
va mieux se sentir dans ces nuages
denses mais la précédente si été
complètement gagnant est hilare fait
n'importe quoi
aussi apprend f6 disparaît plus en plus
de l'écran est
si on ne sait pas ce qu'est ce qu'a
écrit à gaby gaye
ça reprend f5
ouais
on va voir au revoir au revoir ci fait
avec g4 peut-être d'être fou premier
fils qui a aidé 5 dominé la casse des
cinq tout va jouer sur le but est donc
je reviens après
il prend de la b4 maintenant
ouais il va peut-être aller cases
blanches pour le fouet la dame qui
peuvent qui peuvent lui apporter du jeu
espéré pour lui que que ça se développe
positivement
il reste combien de temps dans la
cadence il reste 11 villes 49 qu'il
reste deux parties auraient de quoi même
égaliser là il va être pas mal d'avoir
le pion à f/5 qui va servir d'appui pour
le pion j'ai peut-être faire rock f4 ça
peut être sympa ça via le pion c3 qui
peut être faible
c'est quoi la région bullet 3052 contre
3049 qui sont sensiblement le même
niveau
la dame des trois tours d'un c'est bien
il met de suite la pression sur des six
il ya les partis qui se joue à côté ges
on peut jeter un oeil aronian caisse
avec chang'an des 4 rennes paris s'avère
et duda il ya le pion de plus mais à
l'attack pour pour firme bcia
donc il comptera pas que sur g2 ils
provoquent peut-être petit rouquin pour
protéger le pion futura que ça paraît
logique quand même méprendre sur des 6
ou c3 au prochain il fait h4 arrivée sur
dame pranger deux fois f3 et la dame a
plus de gaz
donc c'est bien joué
il est peut-être faire dame prend ces
trois pour protéger gagner un pion et
protéger le café rock plutôt que
m'embêter avec h quatre personnes
je serai pas embêtés avec le h4 là
puisque ce pion il peut être mal placé
un parfois fort à faire j'ai trois pour
le soutenir
après ça a l'air pas mal qu'elle g3 rock
ça a l'air bien sa chasse complètement
la dame en âge 6 il est quand même bien
là jefferies
qui fait 4 5 on peut peut-être un jour
menace inquiets t3 ou un cavalier f3
pour découvrir voyez toujours bien après
j'ai l'impression que dans les matchs où
l'on s'était toujours bien ça finit par
payer un jour
moi étant toujours mal j'ai l'impression
de qu'à force à un moment donné ça
craque après ils ont plus d'ouverture où
ils peuvent changer où ils ont un
répertoire quand même plus solide donc
la surca et détroit le problème c'est
qu'il va reprendre de la tour il fait
acheter s'ils se donnent de l'air mais
attention à sa dame 1 qui peut être
enfermé non il a pris ces trois il va
faire quoi faire damage de j'imagine
tour h3 d'un pranger 2 mais c'est chaud
tête d'un match de tours age 3 dawn j'ai
un roi des deux dames prend dame l'
échec en 18 à la fin peut-être mieux sa
presse paraît pas pas fou non plus mais
je ferais si réussi à jouer un peu plus
vite ce que des positions sont à l'heure
où il aboie finale où il a été lent
c'était pas forcément très malin d'être
lent quoi il aurait pu y aurait pu jouer
plus vite
il commence par walf 7 il veut sûrement
préparé un tour des huit à un moment
donné
allez ça se passe plutôt pas mal pour le
joueur pour le joueur américain n'ont
peut-être un coup comme f6 pour tout
ouvrir il reste 7 minutes donc ce sera
la prochaine sera la dernière et a fait
retour 8
la prochaine partie de la cadence sera
la dernière
par contre si personne n'a à mon avis
pipi n'eurent pas peur c'est à mon avis
peut faire pipi dans les pampers dam des
cas tu vas voir un damage deux peut-être
et avec des idées de tour des huit dames
g1 qui peuvent arriver à mesquer partie
mais ça qui fait peur il peut faire un
damage de à mon avis il est mal autant
maintenance arana commence par il fait
autour des huit dames 3 tempo et la
laure didonne cavaliers f3 attendait
faut que je regarde ça gpra f3e prend
f3a et sur dame prend un f4 tour prend
2,3 et fin de tour prend d un math
ouais ça c'est très chaud à voir non il
n'a pas vu ça c'était très très chaud à
voir c'était très très très chaud à voir
ce truc là s'il avait vu par contre
c'est fini
prache 4 et là il est il est pas mal il
est plus si mal j'ai l'impression quand
même ça rana leur dit de toujours un
gros avantage blanc mais ça semble plus
dangereux roi des deux
lors des 8 3 c1 dames f6 ouais c'est
plutôt pas mal
parce que faire cailler g4 et damas un
math éventuellement by a un potentiel
darna cas d'arrêt depuis tout à l'heure
mais après c'est aussi parce qu'ils se
faire arnaquer non-stop un qu'on pense
ça il n'est pas sûr de lui il s'est fait
trois arnaquer et du coup ils n'arrivent
pas à poser son jeu sa son problème en
fait c'est tellement fait ken que l'on
sent qu'il n'est pas sûr de lui
on sent qu'ils pensent qu'il va s'en
prendre une petite de peaux de banane
sahara n'a qui rôde
pour le moment il n'ya rien le roi est
bien blindé four b3 il empêche tout les
clous âge
voilà un an il chasse le cavalier voilà
c'est juste deux pions de plus nette la
taxe sur le roi c'est tout en faveur du
joueur américain mais bon ea qui a valu
aux trois qui a aidé a encore qui rôdent
alive e tour ces huit là ça devrait
finir le job quand même là ça devrait
finir le job qui calcule le fouet f7 est
ce que ça marche parce que ça fait
d'alger si ce matin c'est parce qu'il a
joué le roi qui monte mais il va se
faire arnaquer il a plus de temps il
s'est foutu mal autant il sert farhan
haq et aïe aïe adam et y'avait dame c4
il a raté dame c4 incroyable oui certes
faire arnaquer l'ordi donner foi f7
finiens c'est incroyable ce pays se
faire arnaquer à toutes les game en fait
c'est très compliqué pour lui que ça
c'est bien joué
il réussit à jouer vite
allez il va falloir faire quelque chose
il n'y a pas de matin avec avec les
noirs c'est terrible à partie la sarre
anna qui doit s'en tira airois 4k et ses
trois matches à il a trouvé le chemin et
ça fait 3 points d'écart
ouais non mais tu peux pas gagner un
match quand tu te fare nac et enfin il y
avait juste fait vii et c'était mater y
avait pas de père pète et du coup il a
fait dame g8 et il s'est complètement
perdus baril c'est vraiment défoncé un
sahara n'a magique je vous dis tout de
suite que ça rana contre un mec comme
maxime c'est le tarot en un maximum en
forme échiquier real contre sara nasa
peut être adoption
parce qu'il va pas on a remarqué une
barre mais il est il est vraiment il est
vraiment raide à toutes les parties
sahara n'a fait je crois pas que sur les
sur les quatre partis qu'ils aient gagné
je crois pas qu'ils en aient une propre
en fait non mais il se fait mal au temps
mais en soi c'est juste un manque de
confiance
c'est le pignon pampers 200% un conte
jeffrey bell est vraiment pas en forme
je dirais que non il faudrait plus
adopter sarhane à maxime je pense dans
le style ouais le truc c'est qu'il a il
a plus de apprête à plus de confiance tu
commences à te faire un haka toutes les
parties c'est terrible c'est difficile
bonsoir professeur fafa c'est difficile
après quand tu te fais plus quand tu as
pu la confiance
ça n'a pas d'intérêt de 3 secondes mais
bon après si tu gères la partie et que
il a beau être plus à l'aise si tu gères
ton temps il peut rien faire ouais
silure colle et qui lui met plus 4 ça
lui faire très très mal tout cas ça
devrait être la dernière partie de la
cadence
sa part sa part en total clash sur le
tchat
et c'est là sa cianas partie officielle
pignon pampers ça va partir en procès ou
12 donc ça va être au tribunal de juger
s'il a triché ou pas en fait
l'instruction va perdre le pion mais non
mais là il est plus fin vraiment il y
est plus accueillante
là il va reperdre un poids encore c'est
terrible on a des six tours prend b 7e 5
il veut fou j'ai 4 mai relève de tempo
ça qui est fort star hannah la sécu il
voit il anticipe très vite les coups de
de jefferies et du coup ils rejouent
tempo c'est exactement ce qu'il était en
train de calculer peut-être faut qu'ils
fassent pousser 6 vous prend 1 4 1 au
final
peut prendre le g7 saïfi tourbe et 4 ne
veut pas donner eux quatre oui
l'assomption plus quand même il va
presser sarah nay surtout il joue très
vite c'est vraiment exactement le même
style que maxime copier coller là c'est
vraiment le copier coller un du style de
maxime et ses styles très dangereux
salut titom s'il extrêmement dangereux
en blitz
qui te joue vite
il te joue vite et il te calcule ce que
tu vas à jouer il est vraiment toujours
dans l'anticipation des coûts de xu gang
qui à mon avis va va lâcher le match
avec le 3 + ainsi commence à lâcher l'a6
arana pouvait mettre le point maintenant
et attaquer fort le 3 puissant il peut
le faire lâcher
il prend au sein qui peuvent frauder un
fait b4 un truc si tu prend 1,5
il va prendre ses 6 et 4 ça doit être
nul quand même
15h05 maintenant échec j'étais en train
de calculer de trucs avec zoom qui à
nouveau peu de temps trois minutes de
retard tombe sous la minute
oui après le camp encore sa part en
jugement c'est le juge il nomme des
experts etc et il se fait un avis mais
c'est normal que ce soit injuste qui qui
juge ces genres de choses quelqu'un de
compétent 1 arbitres échec et pas n'est
pas compétent fin après les les choses
elles partent au pénal c'est pas les
arbitres déchets qui vont qu'ils vont
juger du pénal
je sais pas comment ça marche aux états
unis mais je veux dire par là le système
judiciaire mais c'est normal que qui est
des juges à
allez dur à jouer ça la collection qui a
déjà plus que 18 secondes
le roi qui va partir en g4 sur food et 7
et 3 5 ou cavaliers à 25
il va monter le roi à fond
moi j'ai 4 et bien il cavaliere 5 qui va
arriver à les faire caler pranger 6e fou
17 3 5 tours h trois cavaliers h4 ça va
être la partie mais xiang qui a de
nouveau peu de temps ou shopping ou
shopping est déjà sous les 7 secondes
les amis c'est le même scénario qui se
reproduit à chaque fois salut iron kurt
hectic c'est terrible non roitg 5 et
surtout reprend b4 tout reprend 1,5 tour
des cinq échecs en première es encore
plus fort il peut reprendre de la tour
et et tour 7 5 qui va arriver ailleurs
encore fou ou 8,5
il va faire foule entoure b6 a surtout
rossi software 3 qui peut-être faire
tourner cette tour m6
avec son gant tonghua temps mais le
problème c'est qu'ils se farhan haq a à
chaque fois et maintenant il est mal
autant et la précédente tav a vu ses
spectaculaires il avait trois pions de
plus être au système poster fouet f3 et
la tour eiffe ci soit et c'est bien vu
les rouages 6,3 g 7 ha mais ça ça gagne
ça ça doit être vrai tour f136 et g63 g7
pour lui sénat et ça fait plus 4 enfin
c'est un massacre
c'est un massacre ce match c'est que des
arnaques mai mais la voilà c'est la
première tirer 200 pièces il a gagné une
deux parties props arana mais là on voit
qu'il a vraiment pris le dessus sur son
adversaire
donc je vais faire comme les dernières
fois je vous repassez cette partie en
complet et on se retrouve dans une
grosse cinq minutes on va dire ça comme
ça je vais passer la petite page de pub
que je vous avoue passer
et on va envoyer ça a tout de suite les
gars
à
emma voilà une
bon moment terrible bon alors j'ai mangé
un petit truc tu as fini de manger vite
fait manger des petites galettes de riz
ouest exigeons que tu es censé être le
favori enfin paulo moi j'ai mis favori
mais je suis peut-être planter une fois
il se fait arnaquer dans toutes les
parties joue mieux mais il se fait
arnaquer sans arrêt ça fait dur ça fait
mal on vous reparle encore cette
histoire de triche dans le dans le dans
le chat va falloir laisser les juges à
décider de 6 à u triche ou pas
c'est la seule solution les gars il n'y
a pas d'autre solution
il ya encore un juge qui pourra en
décider
donc
non non non bah écoutez ce match car
prix on va voir ce que ça donne plus
nage dorff
ouais mais pas mal hein moi j'espère un
massacre non je souhaite pour sarah née
à fond j'ai mes intérêts en fait on fera
un live tweet du procès mais je prône
aussi qu'au procès victoire de
petrossian si si j'avais un prono jeu
mais victoire de petrossian
ça peut être peu intéressants je jette
un oeil ou sur match de tennis en les
gaffes et pouzin pepouna et à magnus qui
a fait nul avec les noirs contre les
bons khenin qui prend le deuxième set du
coup moi je vois bien fiona ferro gagner
le match quand même et vous les gars
maxime un prono t
cash out en fait elle est tellement en
confiance je vais avoir bien je la vois
bien reprendre le 7 mais bon après
khenin c'est vrai qu'elle est solide
dans la tête aussi et so bann pour 17 20
du coût est en fait si le procès donne
donne petrossian gagnant saut ça peut
aller très loin aussi un souhait c'est
sos d'ailleurs glissade alberdi
l'invasion qu'il adore le s à la fin tu
parles dans ce qui risque de chasse
comme d'ailleurs je m'y connais pas
vraiment en droit américain mais je
pense que vu comme comme ça peut monter
parfois je pense qu'il risque assez gros
en vrai je passais des gens qui s'y
connaissent un peu dans le tchat
ouais s'il ya préjudice moral et où je
ne sais pas où ça peut aller mais aux
états unis on s'appelle lui n'importe
quoi
c'est une boiterie reste pas trop mal
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des boîtes
privées qui ont des fois pris des
millions de dollars de préjudice pour
pas grand chose en vrai
je pense qu'il veut éliminer le cavalier
faire fou ici ça près d'un an après je
suis étonné qu'ils aient pas qu'ils
aient pas avoir réglé le truc en disant
en mode à ok vous avez gagné cette année
vous pouvez pas jouer l'an prochain ou
un truc comme ça
ce qu'ils auraient déjà dû faire dès la
saison 2 en fait ce qu'ils auraient pu
faire dès la saison 2 il aurait pu en
fait virer les équipes comme saint yzan
bon bah écoutez les gars juste vous
participez plus quoi soirée pub ça
aurait pu être une option quoi j'ai pas
prêts ils ont pas ils ont pas ils n'ont
pas réglé le truc comme ça bien en amont
pourquoi il aurait fait sa ba en fait
c'était au vieux ce que l'équipe était
très suspicieuse dons qu'ils auraient pu
juste la virée comme ça on en bon vous
êtes trop suspicieux on vous laisse le
titre parce qu'on n'a pas de preuves
probantes may hamm et on voit bien qu'il
ya un problème
et puis voilà c'était fini 1
d'ailleurs on n'a pas revu l'équipe
géorgienne pour une saison
supplémentaire
donc c'est que c'était possible de le
faire mais pas pour ils ont pas réagi
plus tôt
re devient chaud là mais graves se
trouve du contre jeu tout d'un coup
c'est terrible il ya un écart et les
prend au sein qui rôdent sur dame c3
aérien qui avait promis 5 qui rôde
alentour c5 aussi pas mal joué pour
dessein qui va attaquer le fou et après
ça allez en d2 avec des fous car ils
peuvent arriver
c'est chaud de knight c'est fou parce
que guillon qui veut prendre là nul
alors qu'il était vraiment bien depuis
tout à l'heure on n'en pas deux nuls
quand même changera combine juste viré
abassi talent et ils ont droit monsieur
coin tu leur dis la saison d'après vous
pouvez pas participer c'est quand même
chaise comme qui donne les essais qui
donne les franchises chaise comme a très
bien le droit saison début de saison 2
de dire écoutez l'équipe d'arménie perd
sa franchise
ils n'ont pas même besoin de s'expliquer
là dessus il fait nul ils ont tout à
fait le droit ils ont ils avaient eu
aucunement besoin de de justifier ils
peuvent juste dire bah voilà l'équipe
on ne souhaite plus que cette équipe
participe sans même avoir à donner de
raison il faut en tout cas il était tout
à fait dans leur droit de le faire
en fait c'est un problème qu'il aurait
pu régler déjà il ya trois ans ça qui
est étrange en fait ce qu'il y faisait
pas réglé le problème bien avant
mais kosteniuk t'inquiète pas l escrime
souvent un break pour la joueuse
américaine jeunes en sueur la vie
d'épreuves déterminant si que ce succès
je me fiche totalement alors jugement
n'est ce pas pas du tout ils sont juges
et parties les pros un aussi
commission indépendante qui soit qu'ils
soient faites et eux et qui décide si
les preuves sont suffisantes mais de
toute façon même si wes un benko tu peux
pas de toute façon suspicieux c'est pas
assez pour virer de toute façon
quelqu'un suspicieux c'est bien un mot
ces suspects mais ça veut pas dire
coupable suspicieux n'est pas synonyme
de coupables donc si ce que les coûts
sont suspicieux et simplement suspicieux
dans tous les cas ils n'ont pas être
viré
un avis formel à 100% et d'un consortium
de personnes chaque soir un gars qui
disent à 100% il faut que ce soit côté
plusieurs personnes qu'ils soient sûrs à
100% tu peux pas pardon mais maxime il
va jamais de dire que enfin je sais pas
je vais pas parler en son nom et j'ai
même pas s'il va répondre n'y va jamais
dire à 100% que c'était impossible peut
toucher 99% à peut-être mais 100% non
meters holder qui a regardé les parties
wayne on n'y a rien de hockey il ya des
trucs qui sont très dur mais c'est pas
du 100 % ont peu importants par
retourner une énième fois sur ce débat
mais
as tu peux tu peux pas avoir d'assurance
comme ça il ya une trop grande chance de
se tromper mais trop centralisée partie
avec jemâa ce matin et j'ai vu ça j'ai
pas vu les analyses mais j'ai vu sa ré
c'est parce qu'ils auront ce qu'ils on
disait voilà ses pions de plus pour les
blancs mais c'est difficile d'avancer
après des sas au séga nous ça fait
quatre ans qu'on sait qu'à des problèmes
dans pro-chasse league en fait il ya
même des cas qui ont été avérés a
posteriori qu'on savait bien avant et
quelques cas de deux joueurs après qui a
qui ont été avérés a posteriori sur des
équipes qui sont qualifiées dans les
phases finales et c'est qu'ils se sont
su après donc en fait on a toujours su
ce qui se passe en process ligne c'était
juste matin des échiquiers numéro 4 qui
eux qui sont passés de perfs à 2006 sur
une saison à des perfs à 1900 sur la
saison d'après et des équipes notamment
après des équipiers qui sont rendu
compte de la supercherie qui était c'est
même pas un truc organisé par et qui
paient des équipes comme ça mais alors
il ya des équipes qui sont qui ont fait
le nettoyage par elle-même de
l'intérieur et c'est l'équipe à
qui ça arrive s avec le quatrième qui
est allé en phase finale c'était les
premiers à être désolé en fait du truc
du coup à mais bon ça c'était ça s'était
révélée juste la saison après en fait
enfin bon peu importe
mais je veux dire par là qu'on n'a pas
découvert aujourd'hui qu'il y avait des
soucis après ça voilà c'est ça
s'autogérer un peu aussi quoi qui donne
b3 mais ils vont envoyer le pion à après
les allemands c'est pas vraiment un
petit box mais le truc c'est que on sait
pas vraiment
c'est pas vraiment et puis on ne saura
jamais mais peu importe on portait
toujours du principe de façon quand on
joue et que c'était probable que deux
équipes que d'autres équipes utilisent
leur dis mais que voilà on s'en foutait
un peu aussi tu vois on s'en foutait un
peu aussi parce que bon ben voila tu
sais que ça peut arriver mais comme tu
sais que tu pourras jamais rien prouvé
tu t'en fous en fait c'est un débat
stérile exactement robin des bois
donc ça va rien changer par rapport à ça
pour les équipes parce que tout le monde
le savait déjà en fête enfin on partait
du principe qui est sûrement des gens
qui trichent m et que toute façon on ne
saurait pas ni qui ni quand ni où donc
vaya con dios comme dirait mur face et
en espérant passer entre les gouttes
quand un peu comme au title tuesday au
final geffray qui a accéléré
non croit des cas tu vas essayer
d'envoyer le pion des je pense au roi 4
meerkat retour 7 tu t'exposes à toi à
tour fait froid pour faire b3 mais ce
que ça apporte vraiment quelque chose de
d'attirer droit mais il veut faire tour
b2 mais elle est compliquée cette finale
donc fait roi des quatre employés pas
content kelly s'est auto bloqué mais ça
doit aller encore ils doivent pouvoir la
tenir encore ok il va pas la gagner mais
mais bon il va pas là
ah ben salah il va arrêter le pion il va
envoyer son pion vous faire ça ouais
mais bon après on est toujours quatre
points d'écart et le temps qui coule
mais xiang qui se refait qui se refait
la cerise tellement plus facile a eu
tellement de bonnes positions tu dis
peut revenir quand il n'est pas
complètement dominé d'amstar de bruce
lee vite fait quand même un truc là et
théorique ils ont joué tout à l'heure je
jette un oeil sur les parties bon
caruana il va la tenir ce qu'elle est on
des six efforts et duda 12 ha il a pas
l'air très bien c'est trop
hassen il a l'air dans le dur non à 5 à
4 ouais pion de plus mais bon c'est
trois à cinq
le c3 fouet trois tours bouge
ces trois maintenant est sûre est sûre à
5 tours france et 4 s'il attend revient
ici mais il faut sûrement faire tourbe
et 5
mais sur ces trois sur ceux à 5 h au
lycée fabre on l'a vu si on l'a vu la
semaine on l'a vu mercredi dernier je
crois mais ce matin sur la vidéo youtube
il a fait jouer trois heures
donc il prend 2,3 et ef prend tomber
quatre peut-être très fort et sur ses 3
tu veux faire cavaler à 3 ok tu en
prends le 4
f3 ya pas qu elle prend un coup droit
tout reprend bekkat au fc chooz
bon c'est tendu on va retourner dans ce
match passionnant
il est pas mal il est pas mal le nouveau
jefferies le roi noir complète mon verre
de sars ana
autour des 1 il veut peut-être cavaliers
6 ou cavaliers 5 qui vont peut-être
monastère je pèse sa menace tout de
suite
sarah mais il est mal tout le temps ça
qui m'inquiète pour lui il se passe
tellement sa vie à être foutu je
n'arrive pas à comprendre fait comment
ils règlent pas ce problème d'être très
mal préparé un truc je n'arrive pas trop
à comprendre en fait car élèves 5 adam
3,5 je pense qui a l'air assez fort car
ait lieu ici c'est la prison le 6 et on
réattaque la dame
exigeons qu'il est vraiment très souvent
mieux il fait souvent de la merde salut
pierrot
waouh ça va car a lieu 2
25 hockey
ils échangent en fait s'il ya plus les
dames sur l'échiquier même c'est un pion
de moins c'est plus si grave non ça ça
va se tenir
non mais n'utilise pas son temps pour
être un peu mieux en réalité là il va se
faire échanger b5 et prisa d' ou prises
à deux directs il utilise son temps pour
essayer de conclure mais ils n'y
arrivent jamais hélas pas réussi à
attaquer laurent g 8 qui était défendu
par des stratagèmes tactique
cette finale doit être mieux ouais
j'aurais échangé effet tout reprend mais
bon me semble est nul mais je me trompe
peut-être
je me trompe peut-être
la faire un petit coup de hache ici je
pense ici bon bref 8 pourquoi pas un
truc c'est qu'il bloque un peu la sortie
du roi et il va essayer de à la fois
qu'il fait un super gaffe parce qu'elle
surfe ou bouge à cavaillon il faut qu'il
fasse tourner un échec en premier a eu
droit à 8
il va se manger sur ces 3 il s'adapte
tellement bien en quoi adverse
sarah n'a pas l'impression des fois
qu'ils ratent des trucs mais il s'adapte
super vite en fait il a vraiment il a
vraiment une bonne touch en fait pour
placer ses pièces et pour être dynamique
et là il va récupérer f3 il est déjà
plus perdant et c'est même guillon qui
va devoir lutter parce qu'il est mal
autant il proposait à accepter parce
arana mais c'est encore une game raté
quoi mais bon soir germyn axe ça fait ça
fait beaucoup en fait ça fait beaucoup
je sais pas combien il en a raté depuis
le début mais il en rate une quantité
industrielle de gains zhang il en a raté
minimum cinq ou six mais on perd minimum
quatre ou cinq j'exagère
il fait que rater il fait que rater raté
des bonnes poserait il peut faire qui
les prend 1,4 et des 5 enfin genre de
système de londres ou c5 way d'avoir des
la chanteuse yong ça prouve bien qu'on
n'a pas les micros allumèrent le fait
qu'il chante on en entend pas en fait on
n'entend pas les joueurs
donc 1
moi je fais bonne heureuse sans défense
ouais mais j'ai pas le même niveau que
ces joueurs là ils sont beaucoup plus
forts que moi ils font ça à 300 points
et l'autre plus que moi ils sont
beaucoup plus forts que moi j'ai le même
style ont beaucoup moins fort que ça on
va dire ça comme ça
mais encore une fois il n'a rien obtenu
sa rana ça doit aller mais un médecin
qui fait quand même beaucoup de grimaces
ainsi hélas tout le temps y'a pas f5 la
dame preuve cinquième rang des six temps
prend tout reprend ouais ok il ya dame
17 c'est pas si grave mais à ya le pion
dépassé ouais c'est hyper dangereux ça
pour que j'ai envie si la paire ça
ferait plus 5
alors j'avais pas vu qu'ils aient tout
reprend un échec intermédiaire c'est
pour ça que je pensais que c'était
extrêmement grave
mais peu importe c'est pas c'est pas
simple simple
les pions qui les a dépassés ouais mais
là la tour arrivant recettes servent en
fait n'a pas le temps de faire tour des
huit tours cette dame prend des six
parce qu'il ya dame prend tout reprend
et tour huit matches et tu arrives pas
empêché tout recettes ça le problème est
là il resterait ce 34,8 dans la cadence
ne faudrait pas qu'ils recommencent à
perdre mais là c'est insupportable de
danser comme ça à l'écran c'est terrible
c'est terrible ouais mais j'ai 6 tu peux
dany alain mais je suis quand même ce
qui va rentrer une fois qu'ils rendent
comme ça c'est dur après ils seront pour
nike alors qu'il prend 4 0 et c'est
terrible non sans voir on voit pas quand
il s'en sort après taux de 20 ans à méru
seul à alger tour recettes sa part avoir
montré le mans fort et 17 et menaces
tours 8
je vois pas comment il défend après 17
ans fait dame b 1 il ya rouaroua g2 les
airois f8 ya dam des six tailles
l'abandonner justement
ah non ça fait ça fait mal là le plus 5
ouais ça semble finie tôt mais il reste
quand même encore une heure une heure et
demie de match un pour être bien sûr
accrochez vous à vos fauteuils
nous ne sommes pas sur moi ils sont
terribles c'est ce pitch assez vraiment
terrible il retourne cette position qui
semble dur à jouer pour les noirs quand
même mais oui là où ça a été bien sorti
non nous ne sommes pas encore bien sûr
ce qu'il s'agit est aisé si aucun droit
au dessus du lot exceptionnel
ouais c'est théorique sais pas si con en
fait
navis sarine en dirigeante pulvérisé
martirossian ça il n'a pas vraiment été
en difficulté ya et martirossian on
sentait qu'il était un peu affecté par
son pays qui est en guerre quand même on
le sentait ça soyez à son visage qui
n'était pas dans son état habituel mais
aujourd'hui à lyon que bon c'est le plus
fort joueur mais il se fait retourner
sarine avec temps difficultés qu'ont
smirnov
en fait j'ai fait le truc comme il
paraît plus fort tu te dis ça pourrait
tourner éventuellement mai mais le truc
c'est que comme comme dit maxime comme
comme il se fait arnaquer quand même
sans arrêt tu ne vois pas revenir après
ils dominent tellement en dehors des
arnaques que tu dis s'ils arrêtent de se
faire arnaquer il peut peut gagner trois
quatre partis rapidement quoi surtout
que sarah miles est pas si fou fou en
réalité
faire tours détours 17 et surtour des
huit faire tour à tour eiffe d1
mais propose mulatu la joue un peu avec
les blancs quand même je pensais qu'il a
joué
et quand même le roi sur la septième
rangée
un truc je dis peau c'est moi la vidéo
avec le précepteur elle était cool mais
après c'est lui qui m'a contacté pour
une interview en fait et c'est pas
vraiment moi qui ai décidé de jeu fait
pas des vidéos avec des gens comme ça
sur sur commande quoi c'est juste le
précepteur qu'ils étaient intéressés de
de faire un truc avec moi et c'est comme
ça que ça c'est fait mais mais c'est pas
à toi moi je serais content de faire des
vidéos sur les échecs avec d'autres
personnes mais oui je vais proposer au
précepteur de faire une voulait faire
une émission philosophique vrai que je
le relance
je connais un petit peu il est à la
soirée bitstream d'ailleurs pour ceux
qui sont venus ont pu le rencontrer
charles jeu viendra la prochaine
non on l'a justement fait jouer on
voulait enfin on voulait c'était mon
idée après charlie était plus ou moins
d'accord ça ce n'est pas encore fait
mais je voulais parler du sujet du du
fait du fait de la recrudescence des
tournois en ligne si ça pouvait pas même
devenir nocifs pour les échecs et je
voulais essayer de faire un parallèle en
philosophie et je voulais que charles me
proposa un sujet philosophique sur sur
l'excellent eu trop en fait qui
deviendrait nocives dont peut-être en
parlant de l'épicurisme peut-être en
parlant de l'épicurisme vrai
ces ventes corée qui est prôné 5 c'était
une option non du coup pour parler du
trop plein de tournois de l'épicurisme
que le trot du coup devient aussi fait
que toute chose doit être apprécié à sa
dose et du coup c'est cette surenchère
des tournois des compétitions des matchs
bas que quand on parle du magnus
thouroude ou de ces tournois de chasse
comme en fait le fait qu' on est tout le
temps trop et que ce soit trop long bah
du coup que ça devienne quelque chose de
contre-productif et en réalité de
mauvais donc c'est de ça que je voulais
parler avec charles
c'est un sujet intéressant pour vous
mais c'était pour aborder ce problème
des tournants en ligne d'un point de vue
philosophique et et pas d'un point de
vue purement sportif
voilà ça nouveaux échanges et ça risque
de faire annuler une nouvelle fois
ouais mais quoique je pensais qu'avec un
pion de plus j'avais oublié qu'il y
avait le plus rage sept qui avait sauté
ça doit être nul mais il faut la tenir
avec les noirs il faut il faut la faire
là nul en fait elles liées mais il faut
là il faut la réaliser
après je dois pouvoir échanger un tous
ses pions là il reste avec un 3 contre 2
mais fort encore le faire en beach spa
sursis simple pour bessette il veut
faire tour des deux c6 tous rêvent de
ces 7es tour g2 perpète âme et à
peut-être un truc de fouine absolue ça
marche
alors ça suffit pas fouiller absolue
était de protéger age 2 est de faire ces
huit dames mais ça suffit pas pour eux
et leur vie dit quoi à et tour h5 draoui
tour h5 direct bien joué lors d'y re
define absolue protège age ii et menaces
tourbe et 8 matt flynn absolue ah oui
s'il trouve ça c'est terrible trouvable
mais difficile moi je l'avais dans
mauvaise ordre mais je sais pas si j'en
serais arrive à se tordre la messe et
fouine absolue ça
ouais je pense que plus si ça pourrait
bien clore le match ouais sacrés fous
ils leur disent assez fouine absolue non
il n'a pas trouvé fouine absolue n'a pas
trouvé à l'ordi est vraiment fort hein
après une fois que tu l'as vu c'est
facile sur pareil en fait ça le problème
des trucs d'ordi c'est qu'en fait s'ils
le trouvent ces trouvable en fait c'est
pas impossible
ça a l'air tellement sam quand tu le
vois je vois ces ordis mais est ce que
j'aurais pu le trouver en partie oui
j'aurais pu très probable que j'aurais
pas trouvé mais je peux le trouver en
fait ça le problème c'est que c'est
c'est pas des trucs impossibles à chaque
fois qu'ils font la différence
ça va faire le 3 contre 2
il va rester 23 minutes
il veut garder un maximum de tours il va
devoir en échange et une ligne pourra
pas faire autrement
alors 10 aces et une fouille absolue à
elle trouve toujours des trucs bon salle
3 contre 2 il fait nul d'entrée les
techniques de fouine un vrai puzzle rush
et les exercices tactiques les études et
beaucoup travailler
moi j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de tactique pour devenir une fouine mais
bon je suis pas une fille d'absolu quoi
je suis une fouine est je suis une
fouine est
alors dit à réfuter la grand vrai mais
bon parti ça peut jouer un gb rejouer
contre carl scène et c'est passé bon là
il tombe en fait tu peux pas faire grand
chose avec les blancs mais il attend le
plus longtemps possible déjà il fait
passer du temps pour le match et en plus
d'être silva l'arnaqué va faire un échec
il va machin il tournicote quoi
il tourne ni coach va faire du g5 à un
moment mais il attend maintenant c'est
sûr qu'ils allaient faire un jour ou
l'autre il a tourné le plus longtemps
possible et la vg si c'était intéressant
je pensais qu'ils feraient g6 avant pour
menaces et mat
ouais ça c'est nul
ouais bien joué et ça fait nul bien
défendus par dion mais bon ils gardent
les cinq points d'avance saharan à la
force durée des bancs de nage dorff il a
oublié la grave si on va aller voir ce
qui se passe dans le tournoi
caruana qui est peut-être en train de
mettre à mal tahri et duda et king
qualité de moins mais qui va récupérer
le pion à 5
ben on verra ce que ça va donner mais il
peut il peut la gagner un fil rouge à ça
c'était une c'était une nouvelle nage
dorff
ouais c'est une banque qui avait vu dans
une des premières parties ou à jong
avait un gros avantage
ma position est complètement dingue
il ya une pièce de plus pour les blancs
mais il ya trois pions pour les noirs
key ces trois dames a5 et a7 tour c8 et
compliquer la position il ya ces trois
pions centraux contre la pièce de plus
d'un pro b 6 sur les dames prend 1,8 à
cavaler b5
il veut cavaliers des 4 et peut-être
rebondir vers ces deux imagine position
très compliqué hein
fosse 2 sachant échanger et dames
ça fait quoi ce soir je sais pas je n'en
a pas beaucoup ce faire les parties
pédagogique moi j'ai quand même fait le
stream avant et on attend avec tous et
speechless je suis un peu fatigué c'est
très fatigant a commenté à regarder un
évidemment
en effet créé afin pour lui demander
ouais les pions noirs sont très forts la
mare mais sarah n'a pas gagné le match
c'est quasi fini il ya il a trois
arnaquer en fait il est même plus mieux
vision que dans les partis maintenant
tandem j'écris affable il fera une
petite servent à 21h50 22 heures
tant d un juge écrit
échanger ses pions avec son super force
4 pions passer sa réunion à la chambre
juste ou amener amp et restaurer s'est
répétée sans cette compétition là lors
du pro tour bessin qui est malin parce
que comme ça s'y prend on reprend ça
tient les cases
la cavalier des trois-rois c5 c'est
hyper fort c'est genre hyper fort
mais quand je dis perforce est hyper
fort de chez hyper fort c'est
monstrueusement fort ouais ça à faire
six points d'écart à peut-être bien
défendu des 4 reprend ses katas et b de
maths c'est joli je vais montrer ça
s'est calmé de maths
trois cavaliers fleurait bon là ça avant
ce qui est des trois le retour au roi
des huns tu vas être une tour en b2 est
allé encaisser le pion à 2 3 des 5 qui
montrent leurs ouailles à rien en fait
le roi qui par les parents réussi six as
même pas d'échec ils menacent eux deux
matches et ça fait plus 6
ouais c'est dead la cden le match ces
dettes de chez dead
il reste quoi il reste 7 3 par 3 + a
encore terrible c'est terrible mais à
mais le score et fait 1 le score et fait
plus si c'est violent tu vas sream la
fin du nord ouais bah en fait le truc
c'est qu'il ya encore une heure de
stream ici et après je pense femme doit
faire les parties pédagogique le nord où
est en fait je le ferai à partir de
demain il y aura le il y aura aussi le
title tune et on va dire qu'à partir de
demain on pourra bien le voir là
malheureusement tu vois je suis bloqué
par ce tournage tu peux pas faire
autrement
je suis vraiment désolé je suis je suis
le premier à préférer a préféré faire le
dos rond et là c'est absolument
inintéressant mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça
mais un jour je referai de la saison
prochaine je referai pas une saison de
ce pitch est ce normal explique chad
féminin speech à junior high speed ball
féminin là c'est trop honnêtement je
suis je suis un peu à je suis un peu en
overdose
intel ce soir était parti à vide je
prends ma demande afin peut-être la
française web à partir de demain ça ira
à vélo kitsch mais regarde chez naka du
coup non mais c'est terrible en fait ces
compétitions c'est juste c'est fou en
fait en soi c'est incroyable c'est la
longueur des matchs en fête les affiches
en soit elles sont bien ses servants pas
sur les affiches mais mais mais la
longueur du truc c'est ça hallucinant en
fait ouais j'aurais bien aimé participer
aux event sefyu
en fait comme personne m'invite je ferai
un event de mon côté l'année prochaine
c'est pas grave c'était dur d'être
reconnu en tant que ce streamer quand tu
comptes eut fait un truc comme les
échecs
du beauf mais mais c'est difficile ouais
bon après c'est un peu dommage que le
truc c'est que c'est quand même rentrer
dans le top 100 des stream les plus
suivis en france avec un jeu de niche
comme les échecs qui est quand même le
jeu le plus ancien auquel on joue dans
l'occident et qui ait survécu
donc c'est quand même un jeu assez
mythique du coup c'est un peu le père de
tous les deux tout les esport et de tous
les jeux qui sont arrivés derrière donc
je trouve ça un peu dommage de pas ne
pas inclure les échecs dans le sens où
c'est un peu c'est qu'un peu le c'est
quand même un peu le game au dessus du
game coiffe un pas forcément je peux
dire que c'est forcément mieux ou moins
bien qu autre chose mais il se trouve
que c'est l'ancêtre tous les jeux quoi
occidentaux rein je parle parce que
legault quoi ont une histoire encore
plus anciennes
mais du coup à
né du coup et je suis un peu surpris que
même même en faisant ça en fait tu étais
pas un intérêt plus plus importance
comme ça enfin c'est un beau jeu mais
bon après je peux comprendre peut
comprendre aussi c'est un jeu qui est
compliqué c'est un autre délire que tous
les jeux vidéo que c'est à noter lire
les échecs c'est un jeu très punitif ou
faut beaucoup s'entraîner c'est pas du
tout comme tous les jeux qui sont à la
mode où tu joues 20 30 40 heures et a
déjà un niveau les échecs c'est des
années de pratique et d'études pour
réussir à avoir un niveau un tout petit
peu correct donc cessé quand même très
différent ce sens-là des jeux vidéo en
fait si tu veux ghazi d'accueil j'ai
peut-être un pour être à peine mais en
fait j'ai un point de vue un peu un peu
différent des fois enfin je suis
d'accord que ce serait bien pour
populariser les chèques encore mais en
fait moi le truc c'est que je vois ça
aussi dans un autre sens je vois ça
aussi dans le sens où je me dis c'est
bien pour eux d'inclure les échecs parce
que c'est un jeu qui apporte beaucoup et
du coup je vais avoir quoi seraient les
échecs qui devrait être en mode hawaï
c'est génial pour nous et tout parce
qu'en fait les échecs ça apporte ça
apporte vraiment beaucoup
d'un point de vue cognitif éducatif
pédagogique et eux est ok y'a pas que le
chiffrer l'argent dans la vie
les échecs ça apporte beaucoup je suis
désolé quoi enfin on peut en discuter
des heures si vous voulez mais peut être
d'accord pas d'accord avec moi mais les
échecs c'est juste quelque chose qui
apporte beaucoup et qui a apporté
beaucoup
tout au cours du dernier millénaire donc
en fait moi je vois ça dans l'autre sens
en fait c'est l'absence des échecs rend
l'événement chip plus cheap qui pourrait
l'être enfin ou pas cheap mais je leur
parle assez
c'est l'événement qui perd a pas inclure
les échecs et pas l'inversé en fait
c'est ça le délire en fait
c'est un peu les échecs c'est un peu
comme comme la semil en état le fc
sochaux qui n'invite pas tu vois et
comme la céline ans je fais le bilan tu
vois donc du coup en général ouais c'est
vrai que c'est extrêmement positif comme
je vois il ya une relation entre les
échecs et l'histoire contrairement aux
jo wil et les échecs font sont partie
prenante de l'histoire de l'humanité en
fait ouais ça il va la gagner ça là le
pion c'est inarrêtable et ce à partir en
quête d ici soit et c'est fini mais bon
encore une petite heure de match pour
être bien sûr pour être bien sûr là ça
fait 7 points d'écart cette quasi ont
quasiment mathématiquement gagné 1 ce
match ouais le jeu de gauchy 1 oui c'est
pour ça que je parlais de en occident
casey log
d'ailleurs à l'époque au japon pour être
ministre il fallait à passer un concours
de go tu ne pouvais pas être ministre du
japon si tu n'avais pas un niveau
minimum au go way arctique était sorti
ça mike d'alzheimer et les échecs
maintenant mais les échecs importants
peuvent apporter beaucoup et c'est un
beau jeu legault aussi est un très beau
jeu
c'est génial comme critère ouais bah
c'était l'époque quoi maintenant
aujourd'hui sera un examen de fortes
night quoi pouvoir citer rapide avec une
souris et pour les livres des chèques et
histoire fallait tenir tout à l'heure je
vous prie t on parler d'un livre de
forbes est un livre de murray même si
ford a été remis en question il est tard
dans le chatt dernièrement
legault c'est hyper du horaires non non
legault c'est infernal
legault est un jeu infernal legault est
un jeu vraiment extrêmement complexe
terrible normand cela good news
peut-être qu'on va on va arrêter un peu
avant la fin du pull est là parce que tu
vois que juliette aura commencé
d'où vient l'argent aux échecs de
mécénat ou et wyatte pas tout la vie est
un jeu de go dans ton inutilement
compliqué les règles jolie phrase robe
mais hugo c'est vraiment un beau jeu
franchement pour y avoir un peu jouer
c'est un très beau jeu après pour moi
c'est un jeu très difficiles parce que
ça demande des qualités cognitive
complètement différente des échecs et ça
correspond pas trop à mon
ça me correspond pas bien j'avais
beaucoup plus de facilité avec le shogi
qu'avec le beau c'est trop différent des
échecs gérer beaucoup mieux le shogi
d'or c'était une idée un ca de faire un
peu d stream de shogi mais bon je
partirai tellement de rien et c'est
tellement difficile de démarrer
ouais aux échecs qui a un côté concret
cas pas au beau et c'est ça mon problème
en fait togo c'est que c'est très
abstrait et moi comme vous l'avez
remarqué j'aime bien le jeu concret
c'est au japon c'était peut-être avec le
shogi chance est avec legault c'était
peut-être encore et du cou wesh aux
guillemets shogi le truc c'est que c'est
pareil c'est difficile comme je l'aï les
mieux que jiang
après je fais quand même les échecs au
cours je vous le dis franchement le
shogi je pense que j'aurais kiffé mais
après c'était trop tard
salut pierre louis pkl legault c'est le
gosse à être coréen plutôt ce que les
politiques français joueur d'échecs ya
manuel valls je crois que tu aux échecs
et à dsk bien sûr ouais j'ai vu alpha
gouret le gars qui jouent ça la f1
ouais ouais dsk dsk moi j'aimerais bien
faire une gamme avec dsk
franchement la gamme avec dsk c'est du
lourd 1 que les meilleurs ouais ouais
valls dsk n'a qu' on n'a que le haut du
panier des sketches permet ça ça se peut
qu'un dsk soit déjà passé dans le
châtain le vrai dsk ou sur un live façon
il aurait beau pu nous dire je suis leur
et dsk on n'aurait jamais cru telle
façon je sais pas
un produit en finale fait des staffs
vous en rater pas usa
dsk 69 euros
marca
patrick bruel qui joue un peu mais je
crois pas qu'ils jouent bien patrick
hurel quand il ya des notions de tarna
écoutent ils arnaquent toulon ce soir
prix-là 20 meilleurs lots en blitz un
argent que ceux qui ont le meilleur et
loïc guines quasiment tout le temps mais
xi ont ils étaient treize enfants la
semaine dernière cette semaine il a été
mauvais ouais dsk au fmi c'est orange
qui reviennent pas il envoyait masse de
seube
il était bouillant dsk et famille est-ce
que du coup une fois qu'on a un sens une
fois ça donne envie de renouveler ou
paris ce moule
parce que c'est bien clairement voit
l'argent des familles remplissez les
caisses de la vitrine corporate
chêneraie en fait j'ai passé un truc
c'est un genre de drogue les saf dans
après tu as envie d'avoir ton tt et mote
l'instant je suis deg quand j'avais les
mots d'une chaîne et que je les plus
après ça me fait chier c'est bizarre
c'est tellement coup en plus
il va se prendre dans le premier 4 zhang
non mais c'est terrible en fait il y va
tous prendre en fait il va lui faire à
la dsk il va réussir à récupérer à cinq
quand même c'est terrible fréquenter cet
été dit je passe un truc bizarre mais
moi aussi quand je suis seul sur des
chaînes georges stop sur la chaîne de
gaël du coup maintenant vu qu'on a un
peu discuté ça m'a donné envie de seube
et oeufs et du coup maintenant je le
sentirai plus de plus être simple quoi
enfin j'aime bien voir les émeutes de sa
chaîne en fait ces terribles en vrai ça
sert à rien mais ça fait chier quand
même ne pas pouvoir mettre les émeutes
nan mais c'est terrible c'est vraiment
terrible ce truc c'est une drogue en
fait non mais tu passes sur sa chaîne et
puis quand est passable tu as
l'impression de faire moins partie de la
famille sais pas comment dire vrai si on
fait un nul
ouais mais après c'est pas fait pour que
si tu peux passer valentino sais c'est
pas grave tu vois jean sépare est pas ce
que je veux dire évidemment ça demande
des moyens de seube des moyens
financiers etc
et c'est pas c'est pas gratuit ou quoi
mais je leur parle à que c'est bizarre
ce truc ce que de base suis dit que ses
consoeurs qui dit ouais ok sert à rien
c'est leur système un peu bizarre et
après et après une fois que tu es seube
une fois que tu es ça en fait tu as
envie d'être seule tu rentres dans un
délire où tu as envie d'être sabah
plusieurs chaînes du coup moi je suis
sabah trois chaînes maintenant je suis à
bahia elle je suis seul je suis simple
chez botez et je suis sa bouche est flou
je sais plus je me suis sable à la fois
enfin bon en gros tu trust a d'un côté à
l'autre et puis et puis voilà
françois reix en foirant des moteurs et
non moi ça me fait chier de pas voir les
émeutes moi je m'en fous pas du tout
aisée matin quand je vais chez gaye
jamais avoir des votes de gaël j'ai
envie de [ __ ] des émaux de carton
rouge j'ai envie de faire le con quoi
ouais tension qui te manque un truc
quand tu as plus les émeutes
soutiendra du bon côté mais complètement
tu vas tu ça déchaîne que tu aimes bien
où tu aimes bien passé mais j'ai en fait
quand tu as pu les motels te manque ça
addictif ouais c'est ça à valentino je
suis seul sur gotham chez ce n'est pas
ce combat samedi fouet bon alors
du coup une petite pause ça va faire du
bien je remets la dernière partie on se
retrouve dans 5 minutes pour pour le
bullet de suite les gamins heureux on le
sera pas jusqu'au bout si on peut merci
de suivre avec moi en tout cas vous
faites plaisent parce que c'est long et
pénible
ouais mais franchement les moteurs
acquiesce mais là on va faire des émules
les vols de level 3 avec ludwig fort que
je le fasse beau c'est un peu
et bon
fab apprend par semaine
femmes
à
les gars je suis très
heureux je viens de bouffer un koala au
chocolat j'ai pas tout manger quoi le
chocolat est super bon vous connaissez
ou pas ce que vous connaissez les koalas
au chocolat
oui c'est comme les oursons mais c'est
des koalas chocolat autour et guimauve à
l'intérieur ouais ouais belles pièces
qui connaît il se présente
ouais ouais mais c'est fantastique ça
c'est un de mes trucs les tout israël et
lüthi magnifique os c'est exactement
exactement ça et maxime qui connaît
c'est tellement bon bac et caruana qui
va gagner
rien ne tarit qui va le pont terrible
hein pour ariane tarifs tournoi il va se
faire défoncer par bon pour ton régime
non mais en fait quand tu fais un speech
s il faut réussir à se faire plaisir à
côté d'un truc que j'ai compris ça
j'ai expliqué saab l'a d'ailleurs fait
comment tu fais vraiment quelque chose
de rôle où il faut il faut se
récompenser après c'est un peu comme les
animaux si je me fais un peu des
réflexes pavloviens moi-même en fait du
coup tu as fait un truc un peu relou et
tu te tu te récompense avec autre chose
on peut appeler ça une compensation au 6
mai à mais du coup ça permet de ne pas
trop déprimé tu compenses ouais tu
compenses
il va perdre en duda l'ordi donne tout
reprend h3 droit des 4 f 3 cavaliers f4
j'imagine tourache un bail c'est fini ça
ton projet de pions projet de quel
projet de tour d un fini ces jouets vrai
ali reza qui va gagner la première
qu'elle joue un coup de marloux duda
mais pas mal on pourra lire et zalla de
commencer sur une victoire
c'est la bonne nouvelle pour lui
ouais klf4 et la f2 calais prend h3 et
f1 dames c'est fini pas mal fier ou déjà
savoir la partie ouest et finissent
abandon il a joué à carreaux cas
théoriques théorique théorique théorique
les la page où le g4 et il s'est
retrouvé mal en fait
mais après il a poussé la gueule il a
gagné 1,12 à blender il avéré égaliser
et pain qui est étranger
ok il à blender par ici il devait faire
cavalier gier puis cavaliers h3 et
tourer est
ouais grosse gaffe de duda grosse faim
c'est peut-être pas la salle mégère
c'était le truc le plus simple alors que
guillon les gagnants dans la première
game j'ai pas relancer le chrono du coup
on va dire qu'il reste 28 minutes ça
doit être à peu près bon mais je remette
les captures écran ni ses soutiens
italienne a elle parlé super fort aussi
on l'entend on l'entend fort voilà on
l'entend pas du tout non bon alors
est-ce que ça va finir
non mais des fois elle peut parler fort
mais c'est insupportable en fait tu vois
quand tu parles pas normalement mais ça
c'est moi je l'entends fort en fait mais
[Musique]
akiva doute avec les noirs finale épique
ouais ça a mal joué après mais bon
normalement la sarre à nice doit
attendre trente secondes qu'est-ce qui
fait ça m'a aidé juste attendre la
caisse qui nous fait sarhane à la fois
qu'ils plient le match le plus vite
possible
ouais mais c'est gros résultat doudard
quoi qu'il en soit c'est un gros
résultat duda quoi qu'il en soit parce
que il prend deux filles de fuir ou déjà
dans tous les cas parce qu'il prend il
reprend des points elo il reste moins de
temps dû l'être 30 minutes alors à
tanger pas mieux j'ai oublié de cliquer
il reste 26 minutes 20 à peu près mais
sarah naquit joues pâles qui joue pas le
temps il aurait dû ans elle aurait dû
attendre trente secondes il aurait dû
attendre trente secondes puis parce
qu'il a foutu jeu parce qu'il a foutu
donc est ce qui va s'en sortir ça va
gagner 10 points d'écart
voilà la carence du norway en fait c'est
que c'est du chaos à la fin mais c'est
pas mal en vrai en vrai je trouve c'est
pas mal j'aime bien le fait que ce soit
du chaos à la fin moi personnellement je
trouve ça plutôt positif en fait je
préfère cette cadence à ou 1h38 te
rajoute du temps je trouve que c'est
bien on arrive et on prend h 2 mais
sarah n'a peut-être phare qui gère 1
ben non je trouve que c'est pas mal ça
finit en bits veinards jeu au contraire
là pour une future a3 ont du sens
critique des trucs et tout au fait quand
il ya des trucs biens et des trucs bien
aussi quoi malheureusement dans les
échecs il ya souvent beaucoup d'erreurs
qui sont faites on va voir las comment
comment les candidats vont prendre etc
mais puisque mon le début des candidats
c'était quand même un peu un peu la cata
de toute façon on le voit souvent près
de dix secondes de rage ou après le 40e
vrai nom club on joue en une heure 38
secondes séchoir moi j'aime bien ce qu a
lens il ya peut-être faire cavalier avec
deux ici n'en est pas cavaler f2 il est
parvenu dans sa rana
il est en train de se faire bouffer
wyclef deux petites nouvelles ça
semblait vision qui revient c'est
terrible pour lyon il a raté tellement
d'occasions dans le match
c'est impressionnant fait tout ce qu'il
a raté là il est que à moins 5 et à
l'impression que qu'il a il a passé à 4
5 parties gagnantes et perdantes ballet
1 pourquoi pas un retour de xing
hooshang danses et chants de la vraie
prononciation je crois voilà on va
l'appeler comme il se doit un choc ou en
gallo menace de se retirer des candidats
l'embrouillé entre le joueur chinois le
président de la fide qui remet en
question la reprise du tour à des
candidats le 1er novembre
oui en plus l'autre truc terrible à ce
niveau là je j'imagine c'est que dans
tous les cas j'imagine que les joueurs
doivent arriver au moins deux semaines
avant le début du tournoi chong wei mais
j'ai vu que c'était plutôt chang même
que shiang
c'est bien qu'ils matuidi en bullet
ouais ça serait marrant
marrant marrant marron comme en nombre
et la sig aïn salah il est vraiment
dedans pour et votre tir et huang
peut-être ça le soul dans les trucs avec
le koro n'avance à rien moi mais
vraiment s'il se retire je sais pas
comment ils font
comment ils font ci se retire en fait ce
qu'ils ont déjà eu le problème avec raj
hadja
donc enfin ils peuvent enfin bout d'un
moment ils ont déjà déconner dans le
premier truc qui peuvent par faire
n'importe quoi la deuxième fois je sais
pas mais la fille du molard d'être
tellement aux abois avec ce truc là
la fit tellement aux abois
nous on peut complètement se comprendre
à moi je le comprends complètement ou en
gallo personnellement je le comprends
très bien même on jongle qui est pas mal
bon alors
peuvent donner des points à tous le
monde roule oiseaux mais le problème
c'est que les gens qui veulent jouer
avec les blancs et des gens qui le joue
avec les noirs donc tu désavantage
clairement ce qui devait le jouer avec
les avec les blancs comme maxime parce
que ça leur fait une ronde de moins avec
les blancs à la fac il ya des cas qui va
la gagner encore un mais sarah naf qui
commence à faire ça les jouets la
pendule 1 faut qu'ils arrêtent d'être
fair-play là
gouil aucune chance de gagner les
candidats du coup en fait hyper rien
contrôle bien
50 cent des rentes ça les rend qu'il
aura joué juste et randonnées perdu
alors que sinon c'est l'âge de 26 ans
l'entité partir des données perdues est
c'est ça c'est ça le problème
bah la forêt qui la jouent en vraie
sarah n'a surtout que occasion qu'il
avait fait il est quand même beaucoup
plus fair play des joueurs russes que le
joueur américain
le joueur américain et fait le truc
salle au tour précédent et le joueur
russe ne le fait pas c'est tout à son
honneur mais bon il a déjà pris 3 r là
va falloir qu'il arrête les frais un
prêt serait la première fois qu'on a un
tel retournement de situation ce pitch s
et du coup je pense qu'il pourra rejouer
au minimum 4 5 heures pour être bien sur
c foot pas jouer la pendule bref c'est
fou de ne pas être un renard j'ai envie
de dire y'a aucun tennisman de tous
bords qui va se retirer des compétitions
c'est faux magnifique pièce c'est archi
faux
tu racontes vraiment n'importe quoi j'ai
vraiment envie de te ban de partout en
fait c'est tu racontes vraiment beaucoup
de la merde en fait un level en fait
assez terrible est ce que tu as vu nadal
à l'us open gaël monfils
tu as des joueurs qui n'ont pas envie de
calais pas envie de voyage aux
etats-unis à cause du corona et qu'ils
n'ont pas fait non mais c'est
arrive de raconter autant de la merde en
fait marc veste il va finir bad en fait
c'est obligatoire je parlais actuelle on
en met tu racontes n'importe quoi en
vrai tu racontes n'importe quoi
c'est terrible a roland garros il ya pas
tout le monde qui joue c'est à lui de
dire autant de la merde j'avais qui va
plier le match et pas sur un qu'ils
appuient la sarre ana c'est pas sûr
qu'ils l'apli parce que s'il fait nul
s'applique pas encore tu pars quand il
lui manque de points exactement à sanaa
pour plier le truc nul sap fi du match 4
points non je pense pas que ça plie
maximin +4 s'applique pas parce que 15
minutes de match ça plie pas cinq points
ça doit plier mais bon là il va se
prendre en plus fou et six tours 17
s'appuie rien du tout un après il est
quand même débile de pas avoir ne pas
avoir
il aurait pu faire traîner minimum deux
minutes de plus un sur les parties
précédentes
mais surtout que occasion il avait fait
salle de chez sal un calage saranais la
vingtaine ceux-ci l'autre truc qui est
dommage dans le speech et juniors c'est
qu'en fait pour avoir des joueurs qui
ont encore un moyen d'être au top
mondial faudrait le faire au moins de 16
ou moins de 17 bat moins de 16 à pau 1er
janvier quoi marie-mai plein déchets qui
va faire 2 2 et là il va plier le rang
des cinq très mal placé ya pas tour b8
terrible pour shuang
terrible terrible terrible terrible
terrible c'est terminé les amis +5 15
minutes
méfions qui pourra avoir des regrets un
pion qui pourra avoir d'énormes regrets
si on vend sueur ouais non il n'a pas
été impressionnant il n'a pas été
impressionnant sarah n'a en dehors du
petit jeu tactique à la fin mais par
contre dans le petit jeu tactique à la
fin je pense que pour un mec comme
maxime champions enfin bon il y en a
aucun des deux qui est dangereux après
mais je pense que chien pourrait
potentiellement être plus pénible que
sarah n'a je pense je pense que sarah il
peut vraiment l'adopter même
impressions tel le chien qu'on speech
est qu ils avaient défoncé j'imagine bah
oui c'était fini en gros ben ouais
c'était le match j'ai l'impression que
c'était contre eux oui mais c'est contre
shiang début de match compliqué mais je
pense qu il peut franchement ça râle a
en fait il est juste tu qui dominerait
juste de a à z sarna je pense qu'en fait
il pour il pourrait tellement jamais
tarnac et serait terrible pour lui
cherchiez dans l'alcool
il est en train de se faire défoncer il
n'avait pas de pompaire soit ils
n'avaient pas les ponts perse pipe in
your pampers
j'adore tellement ce truc de pignons
pampers
les pignons pampers est vraiment
mythique au moins donné ça le speech s
aura au moins servi à ça opinion pampers
je suis dit
alors pensé moi même exactement où
maxime c'est tellement la plus belle
expression de l'année vrai assez joli ça
et veut tour des huit cavaliers des six
arrêts petro s'adressa est une icône un
fût belle punchline de l'année des
échecs ça c'est pour moi c'est une
évidence et pignons pampers
ouais ok bon ça ça clôt le match une
bonne fois pour toutes
parce que là il y aura plus assez de
parti ai'a reste douze minutes cinq
points c'est terminé les amis on l'avait
annoncé après une heure de match non en
vrai je pensais que fut longue pour y
remonter mais comme d'hab tu remontes
jamais dans ces matchs en fait c'est
fini ouais shiang sachiez
mais les magnifiques
placerait remontrer terrible
aurais-je eu tous en masse c'est bizarre
quand même après s'ils se font tester
tous les matins
écoutez un prochaine partie je pense
qu'on va changer de live je vais
remettre la pub
je m'étais la gauche avec fable comme
titre
comme ça je vais mettre le
ma ils ont fait la quarantaine avant et
tout
le switch maintenant je mets les petits
clips après on retrouve fab
je vais envoyer la pub mais y aura le
raid 1 comme d'hab mewes arnal match
n'est gagné 1 le match il est bien
gagner
le match est bien gagner une partie que
l'ubs on demandera fabing ce fable qui
vous dira je laisse pas à me gérer voilà
entre iya et aujourd'hui je suis h à 14
heures de live on va 13 heures là on va
on veut un peu on peut freiner
ça fait perpète mais ce père pète la
rend le match rend le match terminé 8
points et 8 minutes là c'est bon c'est
terminé donc on va faire le switch on se
retrouve tout de suite je vais m je vais
mettre les petits clips petit bourg est
non me vois pas aller jusqu'au bout là
pour voir ça c'est abusé ballon va faire
le petit switch on sort on se retrouve
tout de suite
ne partez pas dit si le raid